Chaosradio, was den Computerfreaks immer irgendwie ein schlechtes Gewissen haben, ist, ja, die denken, Computerindustrie, das hat sich alles irgendwie aus einem militärisch-industriellen Komplex entwickelt und ist letztendlich Militärtechnik, das ist so nicht, also viele Punkte bei der Computertechnik, wie sich das entwickelt hat, das kommt halt auch einfach aus den Spielen und ja, die Spiele waren auch oft ein Motor der Technologie, die die Grafikkarten weiterentwickelt haben, etc.
Darüber wird es aber heute Abend nicht nur gehen, also es wird keine rein technische Geschichte, es soll emotional eigentlich auch hoch hergehen, oder Mario?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also wir werden uns an den Spielen konzentrieren, ja, und wir werden alles durchgehen, von den Automatenspielen über die PC-Spiele bis zu den Videokonsolen. Also es geht wirklich um die Spiele.
Und da sollten wir auch vielleicht direkt mal ansetzen, um so diejenigen, die sich jetzt gar nicht vorstellen können, worum es heute geht, in die Spur zu schicken, denn die Frage, die an euch geht in Berlin und Brandenburg, ist die, was war wirklich euer erstes Spiel? Das möchten wir fragen, unter 033 177 97 110. Und um so einen kleinen hinzugeben, wo das angefangen haben könnte, liegt im Hintergrund schon leise Musik, aufgelegt von LN die auch hier ist und vielleicht mal kurz winken kann, akustisch. Die hört mich gar nicht, die ist so konzentriert, die hat nämlich andere Kopfhörer auf. Das ist nämlich Commodore 64 Musik, die es tatsächlich auch auf Platte gibt. Und da gibt es heute Abend auch ein kleines Spiel, was wir daran aufhängen werden. Wir dürfen ja nicht verraten, was für Titel es sind, aber es ist schon sehr, sehr special, oder Jens?
Ja, nee, dann wäre es so einfach, wenn wir die Titel verraten würden. Es geht hauptsächlich aus dieser Commodore 64-Ära. Wir hoffen, dass es nicht allzu schwer ist, aber ich glaube, es ist machbar.
Ja, es geht nämlich darum, dass wir eine kleine CD gepresst haben, Chaosradio mäßig, aus Köln mitgebracht. Das ist eine echte Kölner CD, wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche. Und auf der sind lauter ganz viele kleine Soundtracks von Spielen. Früher hat das noch nicht so geheißen, aber mittlerweile nennt man das im Grunde so, wo die ganzen Sachen noch sehr, sehr hackelig auf so kleinen MIDI Prozessoren programmiert worden sind.
Nee, nee, nee. Nicht auf MIDI? Nee, also das kommt hauptsächlich aus dem SID-Chip, also der Soundchip, der im C64 verbaut wurde.
Gott sei Dank, es trommelt, dass ihr das hier macht, Jungs. Sonst würde ich nämlich ganz schön auf dem Schlauch stehen. Aber wir können ja mal ein Momentchen reinhören, damit die Leute eine Vorstellung davon haben, was das überhaupt. Eigentlich hört es sich auch fast geiler an als Midi, also dieses was man so als klassische Midi-Mucke versteht, obwohl es doch viel älter ist oder nicht?
Ja, ist viel älter. Vor allen Dingen irgendwie diese Rechteck-Töne. Das ist jetzt die Frage, ob das ein bisschen matschig übers Radio rüberkommt, aber ich denke, man kann das dann doch als technisch affiner Mensch dann irgendwie doch genießen.
Ja, durchaus.
Ja, wir hatten ein bisschen Angst wegen der Rechteck-Töne, aber ich denke, das ist kein Problem.
Na, wir kommen ja auch irgendwie aus einem anderen Kulturkreis, hier aus dem Rheinland nach Berlin oder nach Potsdam jetzt hier irgendwie gefahren und haben dann gemerkt, dass es doch irgendwie hier ein bisschen anders ist, irgendwie Techno hier als Staatsreligion. Wir hatten Angst, dass wir irgendwie kontrolliert werden, ob wir denn irgendwie auch vorschriftsgemäß Techno in unserem Autoradio hören. Aber ich glaube, irgendwie mit den 60er Tunes, die wir die Fahrt über gehört haben, werden wir da auch durchgekommen.
Wir liegen im Trend.
Auf jeden Fall, würde ich sagen. Probieren wir doch einfach mal und gucken mal, ob wir vielleicht schon den ersten dran haben hier im Blue Moon. 03317797110. Ihr könnt direkt starten. Was war euer erstes Spiel? Das ist die erste Frage für den Chaosradio Blue Moon heute Abend. Hallo, wer ist denn da am Telefon? David, was war dein erstes Spiel?
Okay, alles klar.
Dann gucken wir mal hier. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Nee, das probiere ich noch nicht. Aus Wittenberg. Hast du denn angerufen für den Blue Moon, um vielleicht zu erzählen, was dein erstes Computerspiel war?
Ja, genau, da wollte ich angerufen und zwar ist das ein Klassiker, den kennt bestimmt jeder, das ist Commander Keen.
Commander Keen?
Commander Keen 3, das war auch noch aus dem 386 oder sowas, kann das gibt es das?
Klar, PC-Spiele.
Genau, das war mein erstes Spiel, natürlich noch ganz genau, das hat mir mein Bruder geschenkt und das war mein erstes Spiel, ja.
Mario, Jens, ihr könnt das zeitlich wahrscheinlich sogar genau einordnen, wie ich euch einschätze, oder?
Oh, das muss irgendwie Ende der 80er Jahre gewesen sein.
War das dein Einstieg?
Das war mein Einstieg, ja.
Das ist ja cool, aber weißt du, erinnerst du dich noch an den Computer, an dem das Ganze hing, war das wirklich ein 386er oder ist das nicht mehr so im Gedächtnis?
Doch, doch, das war ein 386er, an dem ich heute noch sitze, und das ist inzwischen schon, also ich hab jetzt schon meinen dritten Computer und das war halt mein erster. Und das erste Spiel, das ich jetzt gekriegt habe, war Commander Keen. Ja, und das war halt ein ganz einfaches Jump'n'Run-Spiel, aber hat mir trotzdem damals sehr viel Freude bereitet, denn es war auch nichts Schlechtes zu der Zeit.
Aber es gab auch viel zu entdecken, glaube ich. Extra-Level und Bonus-Gegenstände. Was man eigentlich von einem guten Jump'n'Run so erwartet.
Eigentlich ist es zeitlich schon fast zu weit fortgeschritten, wenn man so bei den Anfängen anfängt. Wo war denn das überhaupt? Nur damit ihr mal einen kleinen Eindruck geben könnt. Wo hat es wirklich angefangen? Was waren so das Aller, Aller, Aller, Aller, Aller Erste?
Oh, ist eine philosophische Frage. Also man könnte irgendwie anfangen bei den Flipper-Automaten, die wirklich die direkten Vorgänger der Computerspiele waren, weil es zum ersten Mal Mechanik in Verbindung mit dem Spiel war. Aber das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen sehr abstrakt zu sehen. Das erste elektronische Spiel, das war auch kein Computerspiel oder Videospiel in dem Sinne, das fing irgendwie glaube ich 1958 an, oder?
Richtig, das war, ich glaube, auf der Mark I ein Computer vom Militär entwickelt worden, um Flugbahnen von Geschossen zu berechnen. Und das war anlässlich eines Tages der offenen Tür in einem Kernkraftwerk, wo sich dann ein Ingenieur dieses Spiel ausgedacht hat. Das ist ein Grunde. Doch, doch, wirklich.
Der Tag der offenen Tür in einem Kernkraftwerk.
Da steckt natürlich der Gedanke hinter, die Leute langweilen sich hier, was sollen wir mit denen machen, die wollen spielen. Ja, und da hat er sich das ausgedacht. Ich glaube, in einem Monat hat er mit seinem Assistenten dieses Spiel umgesetzt. Und es ging wirklich darum, im Endeffekt würde man heute sagen, Tennis, oder?
Ja, also das hieß auch Tennis for Two. Und das spektakulärste an diesem Spiel 1958 war halt das Interface. Die Darstellung erfolgte auf so zwei Oszilloskopen. Und das waren halt die beiden Schläger. Und da wurde der Tennisball hin und her gespielt.
Auf zwei Oszilloskopen, da stelle ich mir immer so etwas vor, im Krankenhaus oder so. Ist das nicht auch Oszilloskope?
Ja, in der Physik eher als im Krankenhaus. Diese kleinen grünen Bildschirme. Ja, ich denke, das ist halt die Technik, die damals vorhanden war. Wir hatten noch keine digitalen Computer, 1958. Und das war, was er hatte, das war auch, was er kannte.
Das Ganze wurde später noch mal interessant. Also diese Erfindung, die wurde letztendlich weggeworfen, nachdem dieser Tag der offenen Tür vorbei war, war das dann auch irgendwie uninteressant geworden. Man dachte, das wäre halt irgendwie einfach nur so ein Gimmick zum zeigen für die gelangweilten Kernkrafts-Werksbesucher. Das Ganze wurde später interessant, als es dann um die Frage ging, wer hat das Recht, ein Patent auf Videospiele anzumelden. Und die ganzen Erfinder von dem, was wir heute als Computerspiele, Videospiele kennen, die haben das alles nicht so ernst genommen, haben auch dann erst mal gar keine Patente dafür angewandt, weil die haben sich irgendwie nicht vorstellen können, dass sich jemand für ein paar Millionen Dollar eine Kiste kauft und darauf dann zu spielen.
Tja, und Bill Gates hat sich das dann irgendwann richtig gut überlegt. Aber kommen wir mal wieder zu euch zurück aus Berlin und Brandenburg. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen unter 0331 77 97 110. Wir müssen ja nicht die komplette Timeline hier durchgehen der Computerspiele, denn vielleicht bringt ihr uns ja auf das eine oder andere. Im Telefon ist der Marco. Hallo Marco? Auch der Marco hatte eigentlich Hobbits für C64. Und da ich ja auch ein kleiner Tolkien-Fan bin, hätte ich mich da ja wirklich gefreut. Aber naja, hallo David.
Ja, hallo.
Na Ben, was hast denn du mitgebracht?
Mitgebracht habe ich nichts, aber ihr könnt ja erzählen, was ich zuerst gespielt habe.
Zum Beispiel?
Ich kann gerade mal spiel Tatum.
Tatum?
Kennt ihr jemand?
Muss ich passen? Wie ist es mit euch?
Schweigen, ich passe.
Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass man aus dem Osten kommt.
Direkt einstimmiges cool.
Also es war noch auf dem KC, KC3 oder sowas. Also diese Dinger, die mit Kassettenlaufwerk liefen irgendwie. Und ich weiß nicht, ich war vor der Wende noch, glaube ich. Und es hat mich unheimlich fasziniert, weil es sich zwar extrem langsam aufgebaut hat und auch nur weiße Linien waren. Also es war so eine Art Adventure, wo man so rumlaufen musste von Burg zu Burg. Aber es hat sich irgendwie aufgebaut auf dem Bildschirm.
Und es war ganz spannend für mich.
Tatum.
Adventure hast du gesagt? Also mit Texteingabe oder mehr so, dass man eine Spielfigur gesteuert hat?
Na ich glaube, man sah es quasi im Kopf der Spielfigur und hat rausgeguckt. Also man hat nichts gesehen von sich selbst.
Man hat nur immer eine Landschaft gesehen.
Also Landschaft ist auch schon wieder übertrieben. Es waren halt nur weiße Linien, wo sich dann irgendein Haus aufgebaut hat oder ein Weg oder so. Also ganz, ganz einfach.
Auch immerhin schon. Diese Ego-Perspektive ist ja auch relativ neu und modern schon, oder nicht?
Aber hallo.
Kannst du ungefähr sagen, wann das war, dieses Tatum?
Also wenn es rausgekommen ist, so habe ich keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nur, dass ich es so kurz vor der Wende, glaube ich, gespielt habe.
Lief auf dem KC-10. Werd ich mal irgendwie nach der Sendung mal gucken.
Nee, KC-10 nicht. Also ich hab da nicht so viele Ahnung. Aber damals ging irgendwie KC-3 oder KC-2 oder sowas. Ich weiß noch nicht, wie modern der damals war oder wie schrottig. Wahrscheinlich eher schrottig, aber immerhin.
Vielleicht kann da noch jemand anders helfen, weil vielleicht hat der eine oder andere ja auch noch das gespielt, auf seinem KC-X bis X oder so und kann sagen, wann das ungefähr genau war und wann er sich das gekauft hat, wann das Spiel rausgekommen ist. Um noch mal kurz zu erzählen, worum es eigentlich geht, weil wir ja nun sehr, sehr viele Themen angeschnitten haben. Ihr hört das Chaosradio im Fritz Blue Moon. Und es geht im weitesten Sinne um Spiele, um die Geschichte der Spiele, um alte Spiele, wie sie Spiele entwickelt haben, wie sie alles andere beeinflusst haben und vor allen Dingen, was euer erstes Spiel war. Und das könnt ihr jetzt abgeben unter 033 177 97 110. Und schauen wir mal. Das ist spannend. Das ist ein schönes Spiel. Hallo Marco. Was hast du für ein Spiel gespielt als erstes?
Das war nicht mein eigenes Spiel. Das habe ich bei einem Bekannten gespielt. Da war ich vier, fünf Jahre alt oder so. Das war von einer alten Atari-Konsole.
Und das war Frogger.
Das gefiel mir sehr gut.
Wo man diesen Frosch über diese Straße drüber bringen muss.
Klassiker.
Zum anderen Pac-Man, aber das war mir damals eigentlich viel zu kompliziert.
Hast du Pac-Man auf dem Atari gespielt? Auf der Atari-Konsole 2600?
Aber das war, wie gesagt, auch nicht meine eigene Konsole.
Also gerade um Pac-Man gab es eine Menge Streit, weil die Portierung auf Atari war irgendwie ganz, ganz lang erwartet. Das Ding war halt in den Spielhallen ein riesen Hit gewesen. Und alle Welt wartete halt, dass es irgendwie für die Atari 2600 der Konsole rauskam. Und die Version war unglaublich schrottig. Und mit Pac-Man fing auch so langsam der Niedergang von Atari dann an.
Aber Moment, Pac-Man war doch ein Renner, oder nicht?
Also die Atari 2600 Version, die für zu Hause spielbar war, die war richtig schlecht. Die war schlecht? Die war richtig schlecht. Also das war auch ein ganz übles Jahr für Atari. Da hat man irgendwie richtig eine Menge an schlechten Spielen rausgebracht. Negativer Höhepunkt war wahrscheinlich ET. Lizenz wurde irgendwie eingekauft von Lucasfilm für unheimlich viel Geld. Und man dachte dann halt irgendwie, das wird dann auch so ein Selbstläufer werden, weil der Film war, den hat irgendwie jeder gesehen. Und Ende vom Lied war das spielbar, praktisch unspielbar. Also letztendlich man steuerte diese Figur und dauernd fiel sie in irgendwelche Löcher. Es war irgendwie nicht richtig einsehbar, was da passieren sollte. Atari hat dann irgendwie ein paar Millionen von diesen Cartridges genommen und in der Wüste in Amerika dann irgendwie verschabt.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Doch, doch.
Naja, fünf Millionen Stück, sechs Millionen.
Wenn die heute noch da liegen, dann könnte man sicher noch so ein Sommerstückchen abgreifen. In der Wüste hält sich ja alles ganz gut.
Ja, das ist glaube ich von vielen Spielesammlern irgendwie so ein Traum, da diesen Punkt in der Wüste zu finden. Der wird auch glaube ich nicht so richtig publiziert, wo das ist, um da irgendwie diesen Schatz von ein paar Millionen Cartridges zu heben.
Diese Philosophie hat ja Atari dann irgendwann den Kopf gekostet. Jetzt mittlerweile werden sie nur noch als Label weiterverkauft.
Richtig.
Schade, schade, schade. Marco, wie bist du denn dann weitergegangen? Was kam denn nach Pac-Man? Hat dich das dann ins Aus manövriert und dann gar keine Spiele mehr? Oder kamen dann noch so ein paar andere Geschichten?
Zu Atari-Zeiten war ich ja so vier, fünf Jahre alt. Das war auch nicht meine eigene Konsole. Etwa später, so mit acht oder so, habe ich dann C64 gekriegt. Das war das erste Spiel an Jaina Sisters. Das finde ich eigentlich immer noch relativ kennt, ja, ich fände schon von Jaina Sisters, das hat, glaube ich, Standards gesetzt.
Ja, die machen es heute noch nach. Aber Jaina Sisters habe ich nie so gespielt, glaube ich. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich glaube, ich habe immer sowas wie... Wie hieß die Nummer hier?
Böse Zungen würden jetzt ja sagen, Jaina Sisters ist geklaut, das ist nämlich Super Mario.
War natürlich irgendwie der Zeit angemessen ein bisschen einfacher. Gestrickt, aber mit dem Heimcomputer konnte man dann irgendwie coolere Sachen machen, aber das Spiel im Prinzip und auch die Idee da zwei Hauptfiguren mit italienisch klingenden Namen zu nehmen, waren natürlich irgendwie voll geklaut.
Klar, aber bei Jaina Sisters hat man einen richtigen Zeitscroller, so zu sagen, unterwegs sind hier verschiedene Welten, und bei Mario war es ja glaube ich mal ein einzelner Bildschirm, oder?
Butterweiche Scrolling hat man damals gesagt. Dieses Adjektiv gehört immer dazu, es musste immer Butterweich Scrolling.
Torikan, jetzt habe ich es. Aber das ist schon viel, viel älter. Das war glaube ich Amiga. Torikan war das, was ich als Champion immer so gemocht habe. Marco, vielen Dank.
Ja, eins wollte ich noch anmerken.
Da kam die PC-Era dann irgendwann, mein 286er. Und das erste Spiel dort war Civilization und das hat mich dann total begeistert. Und da hänge ich im Prinzip heute noch dabei. Das ist nicht mehr so sehr Geschichte, aber das Spielprinzip ist einfach genial, finde ich. Also Sid Meier ist für mich einer der besten Spieleentwickler überhaupt. Damals auf dem 286er schon und heute immer noch.
Das kann man im Grunde so stehen lassen, Marco. Sid Meier ist einer der besten Spieleentwickler. Fünf Minuten Punkt. Und sonst nichts. Vielen Dank. Und der Robot ist am Telefon. Oder Robot, wenn ich das jetzt hier richtig lese. Hallo.
Ja, hallo.
Nabend. Was war denn dein erstes Spiel?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Lemminge oder Dune.
Das war schon sehr unterschiedlich, oder?
Ja, ist ja auch lange her, oder?
Mario, du guckst ja auch noch...
An Dune 1 erinnere ich mich gar nicht mehr. War das schon Strategie?
Ja, mit Lego-Perspektive und so.
Also nicht der Command-and-Conquer-Vorläufer, sondern noch was ganz anderes.
Nein, nein. Eigentlich so wie Might & Magic.
Und war das ein Renner oder war das nur so ein Special-Ding von dir?
Also meine Kumpel, sie haben das eigentlich früher immer zusammen probiert, irgendwie durchzuspielen, aber es gibt irgendwie kein Ende von dem Spiel. Weil am Ende musst du irgendwie den Planeten mit Pflanzen bebauen, dann Wasser geht aber immer wieder aus und deswegen kannst du das eigentlich nie schaffen.
Toll, also richtig bis zu Ende gedacht, ja?
Na, also Spiele, die man nicht zu Ende spielen kann, die gab's ja auch schon früher. Also das beste Beispiel ist sicherlich Space Invaders. Da gab's auch kein definiertes Ende. Also da wurde alles immer, immer schneller und irgendwann kackte man halt ab.
Ist das nicht abgestürzt, den Level 256?
Also es gab jetzt irgendwie vor einem Jahr oder so jemanden, der Pac-Man bis zu Ende gespielt hat, wo dann halt der Zähler für den Punktestand nicht mehr ausreichte, ja. Aber Pac-Man ist halt auch so, also diese ganzen klassischen Arcade-Spiele, die hatten kein Ende. Irgendwann wurde es halt so schnell, dass es unspielbar war.
Das ist natürlich für einen Adventure unüblich, dass es kein Ende gibt.
Etwas unübliches Konzept, ja.
Aber Lemminger, bist du da ein richtiger Fan gewesen, Robert?
Oh ja, Lemminger hat alle Versionen, also Wintereditionen, alles.
Haben die schon so früh angefangen mit so Editionspielen? Wisst ihr da was drüber?
Äh, Gott, nee, ich glaube, es kam dann 1993 oder 1994 die Winteredition.
Na ja, gut, das ist ja relativ Neuzeit. Das ist ja wirklich fortgeschritten schon. Das sind ja schon mal eine ganze Menge Spiele gewesen, aber es geht quer durch den Garten mal von 1981 bis 94 ganz aktuell und so und hin und her. Wir haben noch gar nicht verraten, was unsere ersten Spiele waren.
Ich glaube, mein erstes Spiel war so ein Pong-Klon von Phillips oder so was. Das konnte man an den Fernseher anschließen und da konnte man auch irgendwie richtig trickreiche Varianten wie Hockey oder Squash, die sich vom Gameplay quasi überhaupt nicht unterscheiden, darauf spielen.
Oh, das ist schwer zu sagen. Ich erinnere mich noch, dass ich diese kleinen LCD-Spiele gespielt habe, bevor ich dann einen Computer hatte.
Stimmt.
Ja und dann, naja, Catacys Art-Type würde ich sagen. Das waren so die Größen, das ist im Gedächtnis geblieben.
Ja, Konsolen war ich ja nie. Ich habe ja von meinem Vater irgendwann ein 128er geschenkt bekommen, den ich natürlich unterm Weihnachtsbaum sofort erkannt habe. Und da hatte ich dann noch so einen ganzen Rutschel von diesen ganzen, was man als so kennt, vom C64, diese ganzen Spiele dabei. Zur Konsole bin ich erst relativ früh, relativ gerade eben erst gekommen, weil vorher habe ich die gehasst. War mir so ein Kistenjunkie. Aber es geht ja nicht um uns, es geht ja um euch. 0331 77 97 110. Wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit bis zu Nachrichten. Was war euer erstes Spiel? Und da ist noch am Telefon der Daniel. Hi Daniel. Was hast denn du mitgebracht?
Kennt ihr dieses Spiel?
Skorl, das sagt man doch immer, wenn man statt Prost, oder?
Nee, nicht Skorl, sondern Skorsch.
Skorsch?
Genau. Das ist so ein 2D-Panzerspiel.
Das heißt, du baut sich dann so ein paar Berge auf und dann werden da die ganzen Panzer drauf platziert.
Und dann muss man halt so Angel und die Stärke seiner Schuss berechnen und angeben.
Nein, nein, da gab es eine ganze Menge verschiedener von, aber das war immer dasselbe Prinzip.
Achso, ich kann mich nur dran erinnern, dass Skorl ein Rief ist, weil das war auf den 2.86er in der Schule gewesen, vor x Jahren. Na ja, wenn man fertig war mit programmieren, hat man halt ein bisschen gespielt. Ja, die Spiele waren interessant. Also die haben mich so geprägt.
Und was gab es außer Skorl schon auch so?
Ähm, da gab es dieses tolle Spiel Ufo, Anime Unknown.
Oh ja, ein Strategiespiel.
Dieses Spiel ist der Hammer.
Da hat man Nächte lang mit verbracht, mit einem Freund zum Beispiel. Der hat dann die Panzer genommen und dich dann die Einheiten. Und wir haben dann die Aliens besiegt.
Wunderbar, endlose Kämpfe in diesem Taktikmodus, Ausrüsten der Einheiten.
Aber das macht mehr Spaß als diese neuen 3D-Kram-Spiele.
Aber das ist wirklich so eine Frage. Ich meine, das kommt immer wieder. Die neuen, also alle, die jetzt mit den neuen Spielen aufwachsen, die können sich da überhaupt nicht darauf einlassen. Aber mich kickt es auch an einem C64, an einem Amiga. Immer wieder kann man sich hinsetzen und stundenlang spielen. Hast du deinen alten Rechner noch?
Also das wird viel zu lang gehen, das geht ja gar nicht mehr.
Na, vorhin, einer, der angerufen hat, hatte seinen noch.
Ich glaube, der Trend geht dazu dahin, dass man sich langsam wieder ärgert, dass man die alten Kisten weggeschmissen hat und jetzt auf eBay zu völlig überteuerten Preisen die Dinger zurückerobert oder sowas.
Obwohl, da gibt es richtig viele Angebote, oder? Das ist eine richtige Kultur geworden bei eBay, was Computer und Konsolen anbelangt.
Classic Computer, oder wie?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich habe mich ein bisschen beschäftigt mit den Atari 2600er Konsolen. Hattest du auch? Was hast du da gespielt?
Da gab es ein Spiel, so ein Autorennspiel.
Und da gab es Falkun oder so hieß es.
Da ist man mit einem Falken durch die Gegend gewandert.
Ach und dann Ghostbusters gab es ja auch noch.
Da musste man dann irgendwie so einen Climber einfangen, ganz billig. Also das war super billig gemacht.
Ghostbusters?
Das kenne ich nur für den C64 und da war es so schlecht und fast unspielbar. Habe ich es nie gecheckt, weil meine Figur ist immer automatisch, obwohl mein Joystick nicht kaputt war, an den rechten Rand gelaufen und ist da zitternd stehen geblieben in so einer Frequenz. Er hat nichts mehr gemacht.
Ich habe es immer gepallt und nicht gepallt, weil ich habe die Strahlen.
Aber das war schon das Spiel, von dem man sagt, erfolgreichste Filmumsetzung der damaligen Zeit.
Echt?
Nicht die Strahlen kreuzen eigentlich.
Nicht die Strahlen kreuzen! Was passiert, wenn wir die Strahlen kreuzen?
Du hast gesagt, wir... Ja, Entschuldigung, aber der Film ist einfach zu gut. Der hängt noch eher im Gedächtnis. Ja, hast halt die Strahlen gekreuzt. So kann es gehen, ne? Ja, verdammt. Daniel, schöne Geschichte, vielen Dank. Zu guter Letzt vor Nachrichten noch den Enrico. Namen, Enrico? Enrico, du bist noch da? Enrico hat sich verabschiedet nach Spanien. Äh, hallo Norbert.
Hallo. Ja, also mein erstes Spiel, das hab ich eben schon an dem Feuer, das war Pong, allerdings das hab ich nie richtig gespielt. Das war nur das erste Computerspiel, das ich gesehen hab. Angefangen hat es bei mir in der Spielhalle mit so Sachen wie Missile Command, Defender, der Berg.
Ich glaube, das sagt alles.
Defender war hervorragend, allein dieses Teil, wo man dann, ja, dieses Navigationssystem, was da oben war, das war unglaublich. Genau, dieser Radar, wunderbar.
Das ist doch wieder was für Eingeweite. Worum hings denn bei Defender, das Navigationssystem?
Defender war eigentlich ja so ein Shooterspiel.
Man hat ihn mit einer Kugel gespielt, das war erstmal das Abgefahrene, also man musste das Raumschiff mit einer Kugel bewegen. Ja, es war halt die Aufgabe, alles abzuschießen, was rumgeflogen ist. Und unten standen, manche haben sie als Fähnchen, manche als kleine Astronauten bezeichnet. Die wurden von den Aliens irgendwie entführt. Man musste man das Alien-Raumschiff abschießen, die Dinger einsammeln und dann hat man dafür halt Punkte bekommen. Also man musste diese Männchen da unten beschützen. Und ich glaube, es war das erste Spiel so mit Hyperspace, dass man irgendwo wieder aufgetauscht ist. Genau. Wie bei Asteroids zum Beispiel.
Genau, und irgendwo, wo man es in dem Moment dann auch irgendwie gar nicht gebrauchen konnte.
Richtig, das war auch auf der Fall. Ja, dann 2600er-Konsole, dann hatte ich im Gegensatz zu den meisten kein C64, sondern den Atari 800 XL.
Wunderbar.
Und das war auch immer so ein Kampf in der Schule, welcher ist besser? Der kann mehr Farben, der kann mehr Sound.
Aber jetzt können wir es ja sagen, der Atari war schon überlegen.
Der konnte immerhin schon 256 Farben, der C64 nur 16.
Die Soundfähigkeiten waren beim C64 weitaus ausgereifter, das muss man neidlos sagen irgendwie. Und es wurde irgendwie viel mehr dafür in C64 programmiert. Das war so ein bisschen das Problem.
Ja und Atari-Zeit war dann, weiß ich nicht, so Pitfall 1, Pitfall 2, dieses Spiel, das so ewig und hundert Jahre gedauert hat, mit über Nacht den Computer anlassen, weil man konnte ja nichts speichern. Also du durftest halt ne Woche lang der Atari da rum und man kam trotzdem nicht weiter.
Das ist cool. Gab's das bei mehreren Spielen oder war das ne Ausnahme?
Nein, also man konnte, ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass man bei irgendeinem Spiel auf dem Atari irgendwas speichern konnte. Beim C64, weit ich mich erinnere, auch nicht.
Auch später schon, also es gab irgendwie diese...
Ja, so Text-Adventure, Dennis Quest zum Beispiel, kann ich mich noch erinnern. Das war das erste Text-Adventure, das ich gespielt hab. Welches? Dennis Quest. War halt so der Fernsehserie.
Also super simpel, so komplett auf Englisch.
Und dann immer so Sachen, benutze Seil mit Baum. Also use Rope with Tree und dann ist halt irgendwas passiert. Also man musste an der richtigen Stelle den richtigen Satz eingeben.
Also ich hab mal in Englisch auch komplett durch Text-Adventures gelernt. Ging dir wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Ja, plus Schule halt.
Irgendwie zwei Stunden Info kommen, zocken hat mehr gebracht als zwei Stunden Schule.
Ja, danach kam eigentlich Atari SP und dann war erstmal für mich ein bisschen Pause mit Computerspielen. Dann war halt da irgendwie mehr Musik ansagen, Musik machen angesagt. Und ja, das ist mein Pension 1 dann irgendwann kam. Und dann hat mich das dann doch wieder fasziniert.
Pension 1? Was hast du da gespielt?
Was hab ich da gespielt?
Ich weiß nicht, so Need for Speed kam da gerade raus, der zweite Teil.
Warcraft 2 hat mich völlig begeistert, genau wie der Nachfolger StarCraft. Ja, aber weiß nicht, so manchmal, wenn ich so richtig denke, die alten Spiele haben im Nachhinein mehr Spaß gemacht. Aber ich denke mal einfach, da war man halt jung, da war das neu, da war das frisch. Und jetzt irgendwann ist auch freicht.
Das hat einen geflasht, das hat einen noch richtig geflasht.
Ach, man idealisiert doch viel in Erinnerung. Man idealisiert doch viel in Erinnerung.
Nachsprechen hier vier 85-jährige Männer? Wir sind auch noch nicht so weit. Aber manchmal, wenn man so viel mit Computerspielen tut, dann ist das so, wenn ich mich noch an meine erste Konsole... Da wird die Stimme ganz heißer.
Aber es ist halt genau das, was auch Jüngere jetzt schon gesagt haben. Die Spiele heute und die alten haben ja doch Spaß gemacht. Ich denke, es ist einfach das, was du in deiner frühen Teenie-Zeit halt spielst. Da ist das alles schick und neu und was ganz Besonderes, dass diese Erinnerungen halt hängen bleiben.
Das ist aber auch gar nicht falsch, Lissi. Es ist hier das Chaos-Radio-Morgen.
Viel Spaß bei den Nachrichten.
Danke. Ja, zu denen kommen wir jetzt. Vorher sei noch versprochen, dass gleich die Musik, die Ellen die ganze Zeit hier schon auflegt, unsere DJ im Hintergrund, die man immer nur so ein bisschen hört... Dass die gleich mal in Gänze kommen nach den Nachrichten, die wir euch ein Stückchen davon gönnen, und dann gibt es auch die ganz speziellen Chaosradio-Nachrichten, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Aber jetzt erst mal zu unsern.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Das Wetter nachts wechselnd bewölkt und abklingende Schauer bei 21 bis 16 Grad. Morgen anfangs noch Halter, später teils kräftige Gewitter bei 23 bis 27 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Berner.
Die PDS-Spitze hat den Rückzug ihres früheren Parteichefs Gysi von allen politischen Ämtern bedauert. Die vorsitzende Zimmerzollte Gysi Respekt bezeichnete seine Entscheidung aber als überzogen. Gysi war heute als Berliner Wirtschaftssenator und Bürgermeister zurückgetreten. Er legte auch sein Abgeordnetenhausmandat nieder. Für morgen ist eine Sondersitzung des Senats geplant. Bundestagspräsident Thierse hat der Lufthansa in der Bonus-Main-Affäre ein Ultimatum gestellt. In einem Brief forderte er bis morgen Nachmittag eine Liste der Abgeordneten, die mit Bonus-Main geflogen sind. Thierse erklärte, dass die von der Bildzeitung verwendeten Daten nur von der Lufthansa stammen könnten. In der Türkei findet am 3. November vorgezogene Parlamentswahlen statt. Das entschied das Parlament bei einer Sondersitzung in Ankara. Die Wahlen sollen nach wochenlanger Unsicherheit wegen der angeschlagenen Gesundheit der von Ministerpräsident Elšević wieder zu politischer Stabilität führen. Bei einem Bombenanschlag auf die Universität von Jerusalem sind sieben Menschen getötet und mehr als 85 verletzt worden. Der Sprengsatz explodierte in einer Cafeteria des Internationalen Studentenzentrums. Zu der Tat bekannte sich die radikal-islamische Hamas-Organisation. Und zum Sport bei dem Schwimm-Europameisterschaften hat Franziska van Almsik den Titel über 100 Meter Freiskill gewonnen. Für van Almsik war es nach zwei Siegen in der Staffel bereits die dritte Goldmedaille bei den Titelkämpfen. Der Verkehr auf Ritz hat keine Meldung, also gute Fahrt.
Romantisch, chaotisch, caromatisch und ungefähr nachmittagstisch. Das ist die Sendung, die euch glücklich macht. Kannst jetzt sofort klarklicken.
Im Freitag ist nur Moon, wir haben es 20 vor 11. Was bedeutet, wir haben noch knappe zweieinhalb Stündchen Zeit. Thema heute im Chaos Radio, Spiele. Eigentlich rundum ein bisschen spezifizieren können das natürlich auf jeden Fall Mario und Jens, die extra aus Köln angereist sind. In Köln sitzen beim Chaos Radio nämlich die Spiele-Spezialisten. Das könnte man so formulieren, oder Jens?
Na wir sind vom Chaos Computer Club in Köln. Wir freuen uns aber, dass wir heute hier sein können.
Natürlich, natürlich, natürlich, natürlich. Mario, kannst du noch mal ganz kurz, weil wir haben ja vorhin schon angefangen gehabt, zu fragen, die Hörer, was ihr erstes Spiel war. Da machen wir jetzt erstmal einen kleinen Break und nehmen noch die Letzten, die in den Leitungen warten dran und machen dann ein paar News, oder? Und zwar fangen wir an mit dem Jürgen. Das war dein erstes Spiel?
Ja, ich bin schon ein bisschen älter und das liegt schon ein bisschen länger zurück. Das war so 1978 ungefähr. Das war ein Spiel, das nannte sich Star Trek nach diesem Film. Und lief auf einer PDP 11. Und da aus X, ein bisschen exotisch. War aber recht spannend, weil man konnte das in diesem Multi-User-System da gegeneinander spielen. Man könnte dann so zwei, drei oder sechs Leute gegeneinander spielen. War deswegen ein bisschen auch witzig, weil erstens hatte man die Quellen von dem Spiel. Man konnte also da Veränderungen dran vornehmen und das auch erweitern. Und zweitens gab es immer ganz witzige Einlagen, irgendwelche Texte und so weiter, die da auf diese Serie abgezielt haben.
Das war auch total komplex, das Spiel. Also man musste erst ein richtig dickes Handbuch durchlesen, bis man überhaupt verstanden hat.
Ja, das war so. Es lief ja auf so einem Terminal, auf so einem VT-100 oder was man damals so hatte. Bildlich war das ja nur alles schwarz-weiß oder je nachdem eben in einer Farbe. Und man musste sich mit den ganzen Konditionen und der ganzen Philosophie auseinandersetzen. Und wenn dann so sechs oder acht Leute gegeneinander spielten, dann hatte die Kiste auch richtig zu tun. Da konnte man eigentlich nichts Produktives mehr drauf tun, weil der dann die ganze Zeit nur diese ganzen Raumpositionen berechnet hat. War aber sehr witzig, hat uns viel Spaß gemacht.
Das lief nicht im Netzwerk, sondern halt irgendwie auf dem Rechner.
Auf dem Rechner, ja. Man hatte ja so Multi-User-Systeme, wo die alle über so Terminals dranhingen und es konnte dann halt irgendwie starten. Also wenn man das alleine spielte, dann übernahm der Rechner, hatte dann so Roboter, Schiffe oder irgend sowas. Dann spielten die also...
Die spielten glaube ich die Kligonen, ja genau. Das war damals ja noch irgendwie anders im Star Trek-Universum. Und da waren die Kligonen ja deutlich die Bösen irgendwie.
Korrekt, korrekt, ja und man musste die auch erstmal finden und dann die alle zerstören. Und dann gab es also... Also was wirklich gut gelöst war, aus meiner Sicht waren also die einzelnen Maschinisten, hier Chekov oder wie die da alle hießen, die meldeten sich dann immer irgendwie mit welchen Sonderkonditionen zu Wort. Und man musste dann irgendwie immer reagieren. Und das war irgendwie gut gelöst, weil das hat sich wenig wiederholt. Und wie gesagt, also ich weiß nicht, ob das allgemein zugänglich war, aber wir hatten irgendwie Quellen und man konnte da irgendwie selbst noch dran rum programmieren. Das war in Fortran geschrieben. Ein gigantisch komplexes Werk und es war witzig.
Gibt es auch heute irgendwie, glaube ich, noch für so diese Kinder-Unix, also Linux oder sowas?
Ja, ja, richtig, richtig. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es noch Liebhaber gibt, die das noch, die da noch Lust haben, sich durch diese Welt da durchzuhangeln und das alles zu lesen. Aber damals war das ein, gut, man hatte aber nicht so sehr viel Auswahl, war das ein richtiger Klassiker.
Das war so die andere Richtung, also es gab so irgendwie diese kommerzielle Schiene und dann gab es die Unis, die auch sehr viel diese Spielekultur vorangetrieben haben und da war das dann meistens irgendwie Science Fiction oder irgendwie Rollenspielgeschichten, so aus diesem Dungeon and Dragons Zeug oder sowas wurde das dann gemacht. Und ja, diese beiden Kulturen, sie haben sich irgendwie so parallel entwickelt.
Also deswegen war das glaube ich auch offen oder waren die Quellen da verfügbar? Also ich nehme, ich weiß gar nicht genau, von wem das ursprünglich mal geschrieben worden ist, aber das ist dann immer weiter komplexer geworden und es gab dann diverse Versionen davon, also immer wieder neuen Features, aber das Grundgerüst weiß ich nicht, ob das sogar von DEC war oder ob das ein Programmierer von DEC geschrieben hat, da kann ich mich nicht mehr erinnern, das weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Weiß ich auch nicht, ich wüsste, wen ich fragen könnte, ich hab das irgendwie einmal aufgerufen, das war mir zu komplex, dann hab ich gesehen, dass dieses Handbuch da irgendwie über 20 Seiten hat und dann hab ich es sein gelassen.
Na ja gut, ok, damals gab es nicht so viel Auswahl und da war das eine nette Zerstörung und es hat uns damals Spaß gemacht.
Sag mal, PDP 11, so die Supasexy-Namen haben die sich in der damaligen Zeit auch nicht überlegt, oder?
Nee, also, na gut, die waren halt damals irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob sie Marktführer oder Zweiter waren, aber sie hatten es irgendwie auch nicht so recht nötig. Die Maschinen waren halt Klassiker und die Unixe sind darauf entwickelt worden und so. Also die hatten es irgendwie nicht so recht nötig, ja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also die Entwicklung von Unix war auch motiviert davon, dass Cunningham und Ritchie, Unix halt aufhunden haben, eigentlich ein Computerspiel schreiben wollten. Dann haben sie halt irgendwie angefangen und haben gesagt, dafür brauchen wir erst mal ein Fallsystem und ein Betriebssystem und dann können wir das Spiel auch portieren.
Richtig, das haben sie aber auf einer PDP gemacht.
Ja, PDP 7 habe ich heute noch gelernt, nachdem ich irgendwie falsch eine andere Nummer gesagt habe.
Na gut, die haben sich aber auch eigentlich nur in der Leistungsfähigkeit zu unterscheiden. Also gab es auch Generationen, ist schon richtig, aber so im Großen und Ganzen waren die nach Einsatzweg so ein bisschen in unterschiedlichen richtigen Generationswechseln erst mit der Wechsel gegeben.
Aber die PDP 11 wurde irgendwie glaube ich noch bis 1997 oder so was gebaut oder 1996?
Ich glaube sogar noch länger als oder, ne kann schon stimmen, 1997. Ich glaube dann waren das aber ein Platinrechner und wurden dann so ein bisschen im Echtzeitbetrieb eingesetzt.
Aber das wird langsam hier so eine...
Mario rünft auch schon die Stirn.
Das ist ein interessantes Thema auf jeden Fall.
Machen wir da mal Schluss. Ich denke mal, dass sich die Normalbürger jetzt befriedigt fühlen, was die PDP 11 anbelangt. Danke Jürgen. Und den Axel noch. Hallo Axel. Axel bist noch da? Axel ist nicht mehr da. Jetzt muss niesen oder fast. Und probieren wir mal noch den Fabian. Hallo Fabian.
Hallo.
Das war dein erstes Spiel.
Ja, ich hab ein Problem. Ich bin ja noch nicht so alt. Und deswegen, ich weiß den Namen nicht mehr von dem Spiel. Und zwar, das war auf der Sega. Und da war ein Spiel gespeichert. Dazu brauchte man keine so eine Einschiebe-Discette. Oder wie man das nennt. Sondern das war auf der, auf dem Sega gespeichert. Und man konnte immer spielen halt, wenn man den Sega angemacht hat.
Das war auf dem Teil, was in Europa als Sega-Mastersystem verkauft wurde. Das war so ein Labyrinth, wo man so eine Schnecke durchgejagt hat. Und irgendwie, ja, so eine Schnecke, wie die sich halt bewegt und so. War ein bisschen eintönig so auf die Dauer. Also ich hab das, glaub ich, auch ein- zweimal gespielt und danach dann doch lieber Hang-On gespielt.
Ja, das war relativ langweilig nach der Zeit. Aber damals, ich war, glaub ich, 6 oder 7, und da war das schon ganz schön cool. Also wir hatten keine Computer, noch keine Computer.
So, dann gucken wir mal, ob der Enrico sich noch mal bei uns einfindet. Hallo Enrico. Enrico ist da. Wer hat dich hier vorhin kurz verloren, ne?
Ja, da war mein Akku alle, ich war ein bisschen kompliziert gewesen.
Was hast du gespielt als Erstes?
Ja, also eins meiner ersten Spiele war Boulderdash. Mit diesen Diamanten, die man einsammeln musste in dieser Labyrinth.
Also, das Spiel hat auf jeden Fall auch den Effekt, den ich dann Jahre später bei Tetris hatte, dass man die Augen geschlossen hat und man hat es trotzdem noch gesehen. Also, man hat dann auch in dieser Boulderdash-Welt geträumt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei dir auch so war.
Dann fielen immer Steine runter, ja.
Und dann doch die anderen Spiele, so wie China Sisters oder Space Taxi zum Beispiel.
Das hatten wir noch nicht heute Abend.
Das war so ein Taxi, so ein kleines Taxi, das immer so richtig hingeflogen ist. Das musste dann immer so Leute abholen und zu anderen Plattformen bringen. Und wenn man die dann so eine ganze Weile geschafft hat, also dann hat man auch sein Geld dabei verdient, und dann ist man schon an der nächsten Ebene gekommen und dann ging das weiter. Das war recht lustig. Das lief auch auf dem C64.
Gesehen hab ich das mal. Ich fand das ziemlich uninteressant, ehrlich gesagt. Also es war für meine Begriffe sehr, sehr lahm.
Du kanntest aber wahrscheinlich andere Spiele, die ähnlich waren. Das war immer das selbe Prinzip. Man muss irgendwie das Raumschiff gegen die Schwerkraft halten und dabei Gegenstände transportieren. Eigentlich ein sehr interessantes Spielprinzip, fand ich damit.
Na gut, dann schließen wir jetzt alle noch mal zusammen die Augen und träumen von Boulder Dash, was wir früher gespielt haben. Und dank dir, Enrico.
Hallo, ich bin's, der Bart von Fidel Castro.
So, nach diesem kleinen Intermezzo im Chaosradio, denke ich, könnten wir eigentlich zur News-Section übergehen. Und das ist ja ein Riesenstapel an Meldungen gewesen, die ihr mitgebracht habt, oder?
Ja, wir haben ein paar Meldungen mitgebracht, die so im letzten Monat von sich hören gemacht haben. Ein Neben, das sich quasi wirklich so in der Hacker-Szene verbreitet hat, also eine Idee, die dann plötzlich irgendwie in aller Köpfe war, war auf jeden Fall das sogenannte War Chalking. In London ist das zum ersten Mal aufgetaucht. Kreidekreis-Symbole, die darauf hingewiesen haben, dass ein Standort kabellos über das Internet erreichbar war. Angelehnt an die Gaunerzinken, die man vielleicht von früher kannte, wo dann irgendwie Hausierer, Bettler, sonst was irgendwie an die Hauswände Zeichen gemalt haben, wo man sehen konnte, hier gibt es was zu essen, hier kann man irgendwie betteln, oder hier wird man abgewiesen, gibt es jetzt halt auch Zeichen. Das Ganze hat sich in Großbritannien mittlerweile zu einer richtig komplexen, kleinen Sprache entwickelt. Und unter www.warchalking.org finden sich weitere Informationen und Fotos über Londons drahtlose Netze.
Ist das was, was sich in Deutschland vielleicht auch durch demnächst durchsetzen wird? Weil ich bin ja schon ganz heiß, dass ich eigentlich nur noch meinen Airport zuhause lasse und dann in der Stadt aber auch irgendwo einen Airport habe, egal wo ich hingehe.
Das Ding ist so dermaßen durch die Medien gegangen, dass es auf jeden Fall eine selbst erfüllende Prophezeiung wird. Also ich denke, man sollte auf diese Seite www.warchalking.org mal gehen, sich diese Zeichen einprägen, sind meistens so zwei Halbkreise, die zeigen, ob das ein offenes oder ein geschlossenes Netzwerk ist. Und das wird man demnächst dann auch auf deutschen Straßen- und Häuserwänden sehen. Ja, für die Wahl am 22. September können die Briefwahlanträge auch erstmals per Mail oder sonstiger dokumentierbarer Übermittlung in elektronischer Form gestellt werden. Ja, das Ganze ist möglich geworden durch eine Änderung des § 27 des Wahlanscheinetraggesetzes in der Bundeswahlanordnung. Und das war schon im vergangenen Februar so. In Berlin ist das zwar noch nicht so weit, dass man da irgendwie mit den Leuten im Amt checken kann oder sowas, aber es gibt halt ein kleines Formular, dass man per HTTPS, also per sicherer Verbindung, abschicken kann. Und man kann sich dann einen PDF runterladen, ausdrucken und dann per E-Mail beantragen, dass man demnächst Briefwahl machen möchte.
Wo wir gerade mal bei E-Mail sind, können wir ja kurz mal durchgeben, weil wir jetzt gerade nur eine Menge Nachrichten verlesen, auch im Chaosradio. Dass ihr euch auch per E-Mail an der Diskussion beteiligen könnt, bevor wir dann nachher wieder zum Talk kommen und über Spiele weitersprechen. 74, das ist die heutige Sendung, die 74. 74.at.chaosradio.ccc.de Das ist die E-Mail-Adresse, da könnt ihr was hinschicken. Auch normale Fragen stellen, wenn euch was unter den Nägeln brennt. Zum Beispiel, wie man eine PRP-11 neu installiert. Solche Sachen brennt einem ja unter den Nägeln. 74.at.chaosradio.ccc.de Nur mal nebenbei. Die werden auch während der Sendung schon mal gelesen und abgerufen. Also ihr könnt ja auch eine Antwort erwarten. Haben wir noch was?
Wir haben auf jeden Fall noch was. Es gibt eine gemeinsame Filterliste für Suchmaschinen. Das Aufsichtsgremium jugendschutz.net der Jugendministerien der Länder hat eine Verpflichtungserklärung an Suchmaschinenbetreiber verschickt und hat gesagt, es gibt bestimmte Begriffe, wie zum Beispiel Wolfsrudel oder andere sinnige Begriffe, die als unzulässige und jugendgefährdende Adressen kennzeichnen könnten und die deshalb in der Selbstverpflichtungserklärung von Suchmaschinenbetreibern zu sperren sind. Die Filterlisten sollten weder an unbefugte Dritte weitergegeben werden, noch in anderer Weise öffentlich gemacht werden. Das heißt, so ganz genau weiß man auch nicht, wie diese Wörter dann aussehen sollen. Durch diese Einrichtung setzt nur die Bundesprüfstelle für jugendgefährdende Medien das neue Jugendschutzgesetz um und darf nur noch ohne Antrag Internetseiten auf ihre Verbotsliste stellen. Diese Internetseiten werden dann verboten und beschlagnahmt.
Für Politiker ist das glaube ich das Wort Lufthansa, Miles und More. Das können die in ihrem Browser nicht mehr eingeben. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Das ist sicherlich eine andere Geschichte. Auch die Geschichte mit den Internetsperrungen in Nordrhein-Westfalen, die uns im CCC Köln eine Menge beschäftigt hat, ist auch noch irgendwie aktuell. Da gibt es Sachen, ja die Bezirksregierung in Düsseldorf, die sich dafür antwortlich fühlt für die Reinheit im Internet in Nordrhein-Westfalen, hat letztlich alle Beschwerden der Provider gegen diese Sperrverfügung zurückgewiesen. Das heißt also, die Provider haben jetzt den nächsten Schritt. Sie können jetzt in die Verwaltungsgerichte gehen. Büsso, der Leiter der Bezirksregierung in Düsseldorf, hatte gesagt, es gibt Internetsensoren in Deutschland, die vergleichbar wäre mit denen in China. Denn der Unterschied zu China wäre, dass wir in Deutschland Verwaltungsgerichte haben.
Wird in China nicht gerade ein eigenes Windows entwickelt, wenn ich mich nicht so täusche?
In China machen die irgendwas mit Linux, um da unabhängig von Microsoft zu sein. Aber China ist natürlich auch marktführend auf dem Bereich der Zensursysteme. Also das Hacker-Tool, Zensurumgebungstool PicaBootie, ist mittlerweile auch in China erwartungsgemäß gesperrt worden. Das heißt, da muss man sich jetzt auch andere Möglichkeiten zur Zensurumgebung in China überlegen. Vielleicht noch eine kleine Sache. Die Blackbox ist endlich da. Die Blackbox, die ein Gerät sein soll zur sicheren Übergabe abgehörter Informationsdaten, Telekommunikationsdaten von Netzbetreibern für die deutschen Stafvoltager. Speziell soll es dagegen um den Bundesnachrichtendienst. Das ist jetzt irgendwie eingeführt worden von der Regulierungsbehörde für Telekommunikation und Post. Die Netzbetreiber müssen laut Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung, TKÖV, ab dem 1. Januar kommenden Jahres eine Schnittstelle zur Echtzeitüberwachung potenzieller Straftäter nachweisen. Haben wir hier noch eine Meldung? Ansonsten, es ist wirklich viel passiert. Es gibt erste Versuche, der Musik- und Filmindustrie gegen diese Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke zurückzuschlagen, also diese Internettauschbörsen. Da ist im letzten Monat doch vermehrter Trend aufgetreten, dass in diesen Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerken Datenmüll auftauchte. Da scheint es wohl direkt so zu sein, dass die Musik- und Filmindustrie Firmen beauftragt, um diese Peer-to-Peer-Netzwerke zu verschmutzen und Datenmüll einzuspeisen.
Ja, hier Katz Kringmuth, der Spaß am Gerät macht und zur Multimedia-Redaktion gehört bei Fritz, der hat sogar schon ein paar Beispiele rausgezogen aus dem Netz. Was die denn da so reinpacken, das sind in der Regel erstmal vordergründig genau solche Musik-Files. Und es ist meinetwegen, ich weiß nicht, was war das für ein Beispiel, ich glaube Eminem war das, dann kommt so der Hook, aber dann kommt fünf Minuten lang nur der Refrain und überhaupt nicht der Song. Oder es ist irgendwie sowas drin, dass da Radio-Jingles drüber spielen, was wir ja auch machen, aber sehr unprofessionell, darum hört sich das ganz scheiße an. Dann kommt immer Radio One, we kill y'all, bla bla bla und so weiter und so fort. Sehr, sehr eklig. Ich habe mich ja gefreut heute, als ich im Netz geguckt habe. Ich weiß nicht, ob das schon kalter Kaffee ist, weil ihr habt es ja jetzt nicht erwähnt. Das war so eine Geschichte Explorer. Das Wort Explorer ist hier von der Firma geschützt worden. Und da haben sich die Gerichte jetzt endlich mal gedacht, das war doch Schindluder, was da getrieben wurde. Und wir unterstellen einfach mal böse Absicht und haben denen dieses Explorer, diese Rechte an dem Wort, entzogen. Das ist jetzt endlich rechtskräftig und dann kann dieser Grafenreuth, dieser Patentanwalt da, nicht mehr allen möglichen unschuldigen Leuten auf den Finger rumklopfen und die für den Gebrauch des Wortes Explorer irgendwie verklagen.
Genau, die Marke Explorer ist wegen Bösgläubigkeit gelöscht worden.
Bösgläubigkeit war das Wort. Ja, kleine Fahne. Ja, was war denn mit Blinkenleiz? Ich sollte euch doch an Blinkenleiz erinnern, kann das sein?
Ja, Blinkenleiz wird auf jeden Fall weitergehen. Im September gibt es da sicherlich noch mal eine neue Geschichte. Da ist im Moment viel in der Mache. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viel wir da jetzt schon zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sagen können. Aber ich denke, da wird es auf jeden Fall im September noch mal eine große Überraschung geben. Aber wir haben Blinkenleiz dann jetzt auch diesmal in dieser Sendung erwähnt. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein Standard, dass wir einmal pro Sendung Blinkenleiz erwähnen.
Ja, muss beim Chaosradio so sein. Ist auch die 74.
Sendung.
An der Stelle sei dann nochmal die E-Mail-Adresse erwähnt. Für alle Willigen, 74 add chaosradio.ccc.de Und wenn ihr das jetzt nicht alles so wisst und 74 eine Zahl ist, und die wird doch nirgends als Zahl geschrieben, dann geht doch einfach auf www.chaosradio.ccc.de Da findet ihr alle Infos zum heutigen Blue Moon auch.
Naja, es ist chaosradio.ccc.de. Das www kann man auch weglassen.
Dann können wir uns das sogar sparen. Das ist ja sehr praktisch.
Das ist ja auch neumodischer Schnickschnack mit dem www.
Also darauf spiele ich nochmal die Sendungs-ID. Chaosradio auf Schritt, nur damit klar ist, was hier passiert. Heute Abend, zwei Stunden haben wir noch Zeit. Im Studio aus Köln extra angereist, der Jens und der Mario. Mein Name ist Max von Malodki und im Hintergrund liegt auf LN an den Platten-Tellern. Das sind tatsächlich echte Platten, die da gedreht werden. Aber heute drehen wir uns was aus dem Stil in Sachen Spiele. Und bleiben wir erstmal bei der Frage, ob was das erste Spiel war, was die Leute jeweils gespielt haben oder gehen wir jetzt einen Schritt weiter?
Ich glaube wir gehen jetzt erstmal einen Schritt weiter. Wir haben ein bisschen was vorbereitet. Wir haben das genannt Datenraten. Wir wollen die Leute Daten raten lassen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die CD schon vorliegt.
Ja natürlich, ist doch alles gebacken schon.
Es sind ein paar Klassiker, hauptsächlich aus der C64 Area. Es ist eine gemischte Schwierigkeitsstufe. Einiges davon ist relativ leicht, anderes ist für Fortgeschrittene. Wenn ihr denkt, dass ihr die Musik erkannt habt, solltet ihr anrufen. Es gibt fantastische Preise. Wir haben die letzten fünf Ausgaben unserer Club-Zeitschrift, die Datenschleuder, die jetzt auch irgendwie unter DSCC, CDE in Netz verfügbar ist und durchsucht werden kann. Die haben wir zusammengepackt und würden die dann gerne verlosen, an Leute, die so schlau sind, die Musik zu erkennen. Fangen wir doch erstmal an mit dem ersten Stück.
Ja, fangen wir mal mit dem ersten Stück. Es handelt sich um ein Computermusikstück, also was ein Spiel zuzuordnen ist, nur damit das klar ist. Und wenn ihr dieses Spiel erkennt, zu dem diese Musik gehört, dann ruft an unter 033 77 97 110. Wir legen einfach mal los und wagen es sozusagen mit diesem Stück.
Sehr.
Man möchte gerne zum Tanz auffordern, kann aber nicht. Aber zu welchem Spiel gehört's?
Aber es ist ein Spiel, zu dem du, Mario, eine besondere Beziehung hast.
War auf jeden Fall eins der Spiele, die mich damals am meisten Zeit gekostet haben, würde ich sagen.
Ist Track 1 auf der CD und da nehmt ihr direkt das schwerste als Nummer 1. Ihr seid verrückt. Das will ich so nicht sagen. Man muss ja auch ein bisschen seinem Gehirn graben, weil zum Beispiel um mir Geschichte zu erzählen, als ich das erste Mal Multiplayer gespielt habe und wie er über ein Nullmodemkabel, das hat man damals noch so gemacht, da gab es noch keine Netzwerke und ähnliches, da war nicht mit TenBase-Tier oder so operiert, sondern da wurde ein Nullmodemkabel. Man muss ja auch ein bisschen in seinem Gehirn graben, weil zum Beispiel, um mir Geschichte zu erzählen, als ich das erste Mal Multiplayer gespielt habe und wie er über ein Nullmodemkabel, das hat man damals noch so gemacht, da gab es noch keine Netzwerke und ähnliches, da war nicht mit 10BaseT oder so operiert, sondern da wurde ein Nullmodemkabel genommen und man hat mit viel, viel Schweiß in einem extra dafür aufgebrochenen Einkaufswagen von Liebl diesen Rechner, Entschuldigung, keine kriminelle Handlung, keine kriminelle Handlung, Entschuldigung, der stand da so und damit hat man diesen Rechner rübertransportiert zu seinem Kumpel und dann hat man Musik dazu gehört und ich glaube, das ist wirklich so. Wenn ich diese Kassette, die ich damals gehört habe, heute nochmal höre, habe ich genau das im Kopf, wie ich ein Wochenende lang mit meinem Kumpel da Doom gezockt habe. Es war der Hammer. Über Nullmodemkabel. Natürlich, über Nullmodemkabel. Also nur zu zweit. Aber wir gucken mal. Vielleicht wissen ja schon Leute, worum es sich bei dieser Melodie handelt. Hallo Thorsten.
Hallo.
Was glaubst du denn, was das ist für eine Melodie?
Ich glaube, das ist Alpineer. Nein.
Was ist das für ein Spiel? Ich habe davon noch nie gehört.
Das war nicht auf dem C64. Das war auf irgendwas, was noch viel älter ist. Also das war irgendwie Texas Instrument, so ein schwarzer Kasten mit so nicht richtig Kassetten, aber so Modulen, die man reinschiebt. Und es hat sich so ähnlich angehört, so Kraktes Bier halt.
Es war eine kreative Idee, aber glaube ich eigentlich im engeren Sinne eher falsch.
Torsten Schade. Aber mutig gewesen. Es wird honoriert. Dank dir. Aber vielleicht ist ja der Christian der Richtige. Hallo, Christian.
Ja, der Krille, der sagt einfach mal, das ist vom Atari gewesen. Und zwar das Spiel heißt Frogger. Kann das sein? Auch nicht. Schade. Also ich hab das Ding letztens, also vor zwei, drei Monaten, mal wieder rausgekramt und hab das Spiel gespielt. Ich denke mal, das war Frogger. Aber gut, okay. Dann nehme ich das an.
Alles klar.
Danke, Christian. Oh man, das wird uns heute Abend das Genick brechen. Das sehe ich schon jetzt. Christian, noch mal. Hi, Christian 2. Mahlzeit. Was glaubst du nur, was das für ein Spiel war, dem die Melodie zuzuordnen ist? Das ist ja wieder eine ganz andere Richtung.
Aber schon mehr dran.
Ja, das Genre ist grob ähnlich.
Können wir vielleicht, Christian, vielen Dank. Alles klar. Können wir vielleicht zeitlich mal ein bisschen eingrenzen? War es vor Zelda, war es nach. Falsche Frage. Dann machen wir das doch einfach so und greifen alternativ in die Tasten. Hallo, David. Hey, was glaubst du, was es war? Wir gehen mittlerweile schon zum stillen Kopfschütteln über hier im Studio. David, danke. Wir spielen es einfach noch einmal, oder? Wir können es ruhig noch einmal hören, oder? Nur damit noch mal so ein Eindruck gegeben ist. Oder wollen wir lieber direkt was zu was anderem übergehen, weil es zu schwierig ist?
Wir können auch einen Tipp geben.
Ja, wir können noch einen Tipp geben.
Ey, wir könnten auch einen Tipp geben, ne?
Wir könnten auch einen Tipp geben, wenn es keiner weiß. Also es ist schon ein Rollenspiel gewesen.
Es ist ein Rollenspiel und es hat was mit Kelten zu tun. Und mit den Sängern der Kelten.
Ja, gut, wenn das mal nicht zu viel Tipp war.
Was sagst du, was ist es? Wow, selber gespielt?
Mehr oder weniger, ja. Also ich bin kein Computer-Spieler groß, der die Sachen lang spielt, aber ich hab's gehabt.
Eine eingängige Melodie, oder?
Ja, außerdem studiere ich so was Informatik-Mäßiges und da sollte man sowas schon wissen.
Das sollte man schon Barf Tale gespielt haben, das gehört zum Studiengang dazu.
Also für jeden Informatik-Studenten zwingende Voraussetzungen.
Markus, sag noch mal kurz was, weil wir jetzt ein bisschen weiter weg sind davon, was er jetzt gewonnen hat. Was kriegt Markus?
Er kriegt ein Paket.
Ihr müsst mir das nicht schicken, also ich stehe da nicht so drauf. Also das wäre für mich für einen falschen. Ich wollte euch sowas irgendwie erlösen, dass jemand vielleicht das Lied erkennen kann.
Das ist selbstlos. Aber das sind doch wirklich die letzten fünf Ausgaben, oder? Der Datenschleuder.
Ja, aber ich würde das wahrscheinlich dahinschleudern.
Ich weiß es nicht, also das macht keinen Sinn. Gibt es lieber jemand anderem.
Okay, das ist ein Wort. Selbstlos, aber unbefriedigend. Danke, Markus.
Alles klar.
Tschüss. Wow, ein selbstloser Auflöser. Möchten wir noch eine Runde warten?
Ja, wir machen noch eine Runde. Und zwar jetzt was, was wirklich, wirklich, wirklich machbar ist. Track Nummer drei.
Track Nummer drei. Ich muss mich mal ganz kurz biegen, ja?
Ja.
Nicht, dass ihr jetzt denkt, ich geh weg oder so. Ich muss dir nur was einstellen. Ich bin aber schon fertig. Zu der Melodie geben wir jetzt aber erst mal überhaupt keinen Tipp, oder? Da wollen wir mal gucken, wie schnell es geht, würde ich sagen.
Das ist ja auch Jens Liebling. Auf jeder Autofahrt höre ich dieses Lied.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn man das nur so 30 Sekunden hört, dann ist das ganz okay, aber in dem Intro des Spiels hat es mich immer ziemlich fertig gemacht nach einer Zeit. Vor allen Dingen meine Mutter kam immer irgendwann rein und meinte so Mach jetzt das Ding aus!
Es gibt übrigens auch eine geniale Acapella-Version von diesem Lied.
Wirklich? Haben wir die auch dabei?
Die haben wir leider nicht dabei, aber die ist schön.
Auch die hat mich jetzt auf die Acapella-Version gefreut.
Na ja, irgendwie von Jünglingen im Stimmbruch gesungen. Also ist mehr was für Feinschmähler.
0373-97-97-1-1-0. Worum es eigentlich geht, ist, ihr mögt erkennen, um welches Spiel es sich dabei handelt. Denn das war die Titelmelodie eines Spiels. Und wir haben zumindest das Gefühl, dass wir es hier beim Chaosradio ein bisschen einfacher damit gemacht haben, als bei Bart's Tale. Ihr solltet erkennen, worum es sich handelt. Und dann gibt es die letzten fünf Ausgaben der Datenschleuder zu gewinnen. Am Telefon ist der Felix, namens Felix. Was glaubst du, was war es? Ähm, derbe daneben, Felix. Viel brutaler, schon damals kritisiert. Überhaupt nicht Gianna. Aber egal, ein Versuch. Dank dir, Felix. Hey, eine ganze Firma ruft an. Was denkst du, was ist es? Nein.
Auch noch nicht mal das gleiche Genre. Auch nicht.
Ja, danke auch. Tschüss. Dann probieren wir doch mal den Sven. Ich stippe mal auf Turrican. Turrican? Ist heute Abend schon mal gefallen, aber da brauche ich nur kurz einen Jens anzugucken, der sagt... Leider nicht. Danke dir. Tschüss. Ach Mensch, ach Mensch, ach Mensch, ach Mensch. Dann weiß es vielleicht der Ralf. Was denkst du, was ist es?
Ähm, ich glaube, es war International Karate.
Wie lasst das aber auch daneben?
Nicht ganz. Also es ist der gleiche Komponist.
Nein, das weiß der Jens sogar.
Ja, Ron Hubbard, der irgendwie damals viel geschrieben hat, hat die Musik von International Karate und von dem gesuchten Spiel gemacht.
So, jetzt muss ich aber mal ganz kurz reingeretschen, weil das ist so ein bisschen moralisch-ethische Sache. Der, der vorhin gewonnen hat bei Bart's Tale, der hat seinen Dings ja nicht abgegeben. Und wenn der Ralf das quasi so subkutant spürt, dass das der gleiche Komponist ist, dann hat das doch eigentlich was verdient, oder? Ralf, wirst du glücklich, wenn wir dir fünf Ausgaben der Datenschleuder zukommen lassen, die wir haben? Sehr gut, Ralf. Dann hast du es doch gewonnen, mit diesem, naja, Halbwissen Gefährlichem.
Aber vielleicht weißt du es doch irgendwie so, wenn wir jetzt sagen, du solltest auf Kommando mal sagen, was das für ein Spiel gewesen sein könnte.
Nö, weiß noch nicht, ist aber auch nicht so schlimm. Ralf, dank dir. Dafür weiß es nämlich der Arne, das weiß ich schon. Hallo Arne. Was ist es denn? Richtig. Hast du das selber gespielt früher?
Viel, ja, ja.
War aber schon ein bisschen brutal, oder? Arne, du bist jetzt 40 Jahre alt.
Ja.
In welchem Alter hat dich das ungefähr geprägt? Wann hast du dieses Spiel gespielt?
Oh, wann habe ich mein C64 gekauft? 1984.
1994, muss ich jetzt zurückrechnen?
Also 22.
Also, da besteht die Gefahr der sozialethischen Dessorientierung nicht mehr so.
Nicht mehr, nee.
Da konntest du damit umgehen, Arne. Deswegen können wir die auch, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, für die letzten fünf Ausgaben der Datenschleuder zukommen lassen. Wow, so einfach war es dann doch wieder nicht. Weil man das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so im Ohr hat. Aber es gibt tatsächlich noch eine Menge Leute, die 64er im Keller stehen haben. Ich finde ja, diese Aktion, das ist jetzt unabhängig davon, aber Apple macht es ja momentan so, dass man bei Apple einen neuen Rechner bekommt. Wenn man seinen alten abgibt, kriegt man richtig viel Asche dafür. Machen die das noch? Ich glaube ja. Ja, da bin ich nämlich, das war sehr schön. Ich war nämlich zufällig im Laden und dann kamen so zwei Studenten an und guckten wie, sie waren bestimmt 27, 28, guckten aber wie fünf und sieben und hatten so einen ganz alten Rechner auf dem Arm und so. Und das Tolle war, die hatten den im Keller und die hatten den halt nicht weggeworfen, weil sie ihre Mutter damals überredet haben, es nicht zu tun. Und jetzt haben sie damit Kohle gemacht.
Was war das?
Ich glaube ja, also irgendwas, was schon ziemlich kaputt war.
Das war ja auch eine Architektur. Apple konnte man ja gar nicht drauf spielen.
Es gab Spiele für Apple II.
Prince of Persia?
Prince of Persia, natürlich. Klasse, also auch wieder dieser Tetris-Effekt. Man macht die Augen zu und sieht das Spiel immer noch.
Butterweiches Scrolling hatte man da aber nur auf dem Amiga.
Wenn ihr das sehen könnt, das ist ja nur Radio, aber hier im Studio, da tun sich Abgründe auf. Ungefähr drei bis vier Meter breit, aber 1.000 Meter tief. Die reißen immer weiter auf, wenn es hier zu diesen Diskussionen kommt. Apropos Diskussionen, da könnte es jetzt auch mal wieder zu kommen. Ich denke mal, wir könnten nachher nochmal spielen innerhalb des Blue Moons und noch ein paar Titel zum Erkennen geben. Aber jetzt sollte doch mal das Klönen weitergehen, oder?
Ja, können wir machen. Wir waren ja mit dieser Zeitleiste nicht allzu weit gekommen, weil wir uns so lange an diesem Tennis for Two aus dem Kernkraftwerk aufgehalten hatten. Aber es ging dann ja irgendwie auch nochmal weiter. 1963 kam dann das Spiel Space War raus, auf der PDP 1. Das war der Vorläufer von der PDP 11, die wir eben schon durchgehielt hatten. Und wurde am MRT entwickelt. Das ging zurück auf die Hacker, die gesagt haben, jetzt machen wir aber mal ein Computer spielen. Das war eine total verrückte Idee, auf so einer Kiste, die sich große Unis, Verteidigungsministerium etc. solche Leute so etwas leisten konnten, da dann ein Computerspiel zu machen. Das Spielprinzip, das kennt fast jeder, ist ein bisschen so ähnlich wie Asteroids. Zwei Raumschiffe fliegen aufeinander zu, fliegen um eine Sonne, müssen irgendwie der Sonne ausweichen, versuchen nicht in die Gravitation zu kommen und sich dann halt abschießen. Damals war die Grafik noch primitiv und aus dem Grund hat man dann auch bevorzugt fantastische Hintergründe oder sowas genommen, sowas wie Weltraum. Das kannte halt keiner. Wenn man jetzt eine Sport-Simulation genommen hätte, dann hätte man gleich auf Anhieb gesehen, dass die Grafik nicht so tolle ist. Das war 1963. 1967 ging es dann los mit dieser kommerziellen Schiene der Computer- und Videospiele. Ein deutscher Einwanderer namens Ralf Baer, der vor den Nazis gefürchtet war, erfand etwas, was er als TV-Gaming-Display bezeichnete. Das war sozusagen direkt der Vorläufer von Pong.
Ralf Baer ist auch so eine Person, da scheiden sich vielleicht so ein bisschen die Geister. Der hat ja dann, also das zeigt sich das auch ganz deutlich, mit dem Militär zusammengearbeitet. Seine ersten Versionen, die hat er dann für die entwickelt. Da wurde mit so einer Laser-Pistole auf virtuelle Zielscheiben geschossen. Hat aber wohl ziemlich schnell gemerkt, dass das nichts wird mit dieser Rüstungsfirma. Und ja, hat sich das aber trotzdem lizenzieren lassen damals.
Das Ganze lief dann irgendwie unter dem Namen Magnavox Odyssey, einer kommerziellen Variante und in Europa glaube ich von Philips vertrieben oder so. Da kennen es dann vielleicht noch einige Leute. 1971 tauchte eine Person auf der Bildfläche auf, die hieß Nolan Baschnell, der dann eine Firma gegründet hat, um Computerunterhaltungsgeräte zu verkaufen. Und das Spiel, was er sich vorgestellt hat, da war eine Umsetzung von diesem Spacewar von MIT, nannte sich Computerspace. Das ganze Ding war ein totaler Flop. Es war zu komplex. Die Menschen haben einfach nicht verstanden, was sie da mit diesem Fernseher und den Geräten da machen sollten. Und es floppte irgendwie total.
Es gab 1500 Stück davon, um das mal so deutlich zu machen, in welchen Dimensionen sich das bewegte. Das Magnavox wurde, dieses Odyssey wurde glaube ich 100.000 Mal verkauft.
Und bei der nächsten Geschichte, der nächsten Spielautomati, die dieser Nolan Baschnell für seine Firma hat entwickeln lassen, hat das dann ein bisschen einfacher gehalten. Mittlerweile hat er dann auch einen richtig coolen Namen für diese Firma gefunden. Er hat sich überlegt, weil er damals fanatischer Spiele dieses japanischen Brettspiels Go war, er nimmt einfach einen Begriff aus diesem Go-Spiel, dieses was wir beim Schach als Schach bezeichnet würden, irgendwie auf japanisch, ich werde gewinnen und das passt auf japanisch halt Atari. Und danach hat er seine Firma benannt. Das Spiel war eigentlich eine Übung für seinen Ingenieur, was er gedacht hat. Und es ging darum, irgendwie zwei Tennisschläger auf dem Computer zu bewegen, auf dem Bildschirm zu bewegen. Und im Gegensatz zu Computerspace, was irgendwie hochkomplex war, man musste tausend Tasten kombinationen können, und es leichte da bei der Anleitung irgendwie ein Satz. Avoid missing ball for highscore.
Konnte man auch betrunken noch verstehen.
Genau, das war ein Designkriterium. Muss ein Betrunkener in der Kneipe verstehen können.
Automaten standen ja damals noch in Kneipen.
Das ist glaube ich auch etwas, was in Deutschland so ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist. Also wir hatten keine Arkade-Kultur in Deutschland. Wies es dann gleich irgendwie immer mit Jugendschutz und das sind Geldspielautomaten etc. Das heißt, wir hatten irgendwie keine Kultur, dass wirklich Arkade-Automaten bei uns in Kneipen standen. Also man hat es ja manchmal irgendwie an Flughäfen gesehen oder sowas. Wäre eigentlich auch mal eine Frage an die Hörer, ob die Hörer an diesen Arkade-Automaten was gespielt haben.
Man tut sich ja auch heute noch schwerer mit in Deutschland. Also wenn ich heute lese, dass in Berlin Internet-Cafés von der Polizei durchsucht werden, weil man da Computerspiele machen kann und das dann kein Internet-Café mehr ist, sondern eine Spielhalle und dann der Jugendschutz greift, man tut sich schon schwer damit.
Wollen wir das denn mit reinnehmen, wenn wir die Frage an die Hörer stellen, dass es jetzt nicht nur um diese klassischen Arkade-Automaten geht, sondern um auch die Fortsetzung dieser Dadel-Kultur, die sich mittlerweile in den letzten Höhlen findet, wo sich halt acht Leute einfach mit ihren privaten Rechnern zusammen tun und da ein klassisches Lahn-Café aufmachen sollen?
Ja, genau. Also ich komme, um das kurz einzuschieben, ich war vor ein paar Monaten im März in Korea und habe dort irgendwie unglaubliche Dinge gesehen. Das, was hier in Deutschland vielleicht ein bisschen, also Internet-Cafés oder sowas, hat hier so eine Ruhe, das ist so 90er, das hat irgendwie nie wirklich funktioniert und so weiter.
Entschuldigung, aber momentan ist alles irgendwie 90er, selbst die Börse ist 90er, es ist alles 90er, es klappt ja überhaupt nichts mehr.
Jaja, genau. Also in Korea ist es anders, also nicht nur, dass dort irgendwie 52 Prozent aller Haushalte DSL haben, also die Breitband-Vernetzung ist da ein bisschen weiter fortgeschritten als hier, also mehr als die Hälfte der Bevölkerung hat halt Zugriff drauf. Es gibt halt auch diese Spiele-Cafés, PC-Bang heißen die da, und da sitzen wirklich 24 Stunden am Tag Leute und spielen alle Spiele. Gewaltdiskussionen wird da eher nicht geführt, es sind halt Spiele und Spiele sind für Kinder und was soll man da irgendwie über, ist doch alles nur virtuelles Blut und sowas wird das dann halt gesehen und tagsüber halt irgendwie schulschwänzende Kids, die da irgendwie spielen und abends dann halt noch Leute, die nach Büroschluss da irgendwie rumsetzen. Also da hat sich wirklich eine richtige Kultur entwickelt mit Ligen etc.
Fernsehübertragungen.
Genau, das ist ganz ganz anders als hier in Deutschland.
Auch so die Erwachsenen-Fraktionen dann abends?
Ja, genau.
Die sich das als Entertainment quasi reinzielen, Kinoersatz und sowas. Die kommen da wirklich hin.
Kostet auch wirklich fast nichts, also ja, paar Cent oder sowas für die Stunde und da hat man dann wirklich richtig schnelles Internet und wird auch eigentlich nicht benutzt, um mal Hotmail, E-Mail zu checken oder sowas, sondern da sitzen nur Gamer.
Tja, die Gamer könnten ja auch mal anrufen unter 033 177 97 11 0, und sich beim Chaosradio melden, denn die Frage geht an euch weiter in Berlin und Brandenburg. Wie viel geht ihr denn so in so Lahncafés oder wie viel hängt ihr euch an? Zum Beispiel so einen Arcade-Automaten, das ist ja kaum noch zu finden. Also meistens sind die mittlerweile total schlecht und das Einzige, was man noch findet, sind eigentlich Flipper, oder? Flipper ist noch das Schönste, also das ist das, was man noch so entdecken kann. Ja, und vor allen Dingen, ob ihr sowas auch noch selber organisiert. Es ist ja ein bisschen runtergegangen irgendwie die letzte Zeit und dann hat so ein Boom wieder erfahren durch die Counter-Strike-Indizierung, die anstehende, wo sich alle gewehrt haben und gesagt haben, man muss das auf LAN-Partys weiter erlauben und es darf nicht verschwinden und die Szene muss weiterleben und so. Wenn ihr dazu gehört, 0373-97-110 ist die Nummer für heute Abend. Aber lasst uns in der Chronologie noch ein Stückchen weitergehen.
Was dann sicherlich interessant war, also nachdem Pong so ein Riesenerfolg war, gibt es auch diese hübsche Legende. Man weiß nicht genau, wie viel davon war, dass dieser Pong-Automat aufgestellt wurde, in so einer Kneipe überhaupt sich Ingenieure verkehrten. Und nach einer Woche rief dann jemand bei Atari an und sagte, Scheiß-Automat, funktioniert gar nicht. Sofort ist ein Techniker rausgefahren, hat gesehen, der funktioniert tatsächlich nicht. Das Spiel war so dermaßen beliebt, dass der Munzeingabeschlitz halt verstopft war. Das Ding nahm einfach keine Münzen mehr an. Und von da an wusste Atari dann, okay, wir stoppen die Verhandlungen, dass wir das Ding in Lizenz verkaufen, wir stellen das selber her und werden damit steinreich. Was dann auch wirklich geklappt hat bei Atari. Zumindest in den 70er Jahren, wo so die Goldene Zeit der Videospiele waren. 1972 gab es dann irgendwie noch eine Geschichte, dass das erste Adventure, das Text-Adventure, auf den Markt kam, auch auf der PDP-1, also die Gaming-Plattform.
Wie oft wurde die verkauft in Amerika? Ich glaube, keine 100 Stück oder so. Nur Großrechner an Universitäten, muss man sich vorstellen. Aber Adventure war sicherlich das erste große Adventure.
Geschrieben von so einem Hobbyhülenforscher, der die Höhlen in seiner Heimatregion abgebildet hat, das dann mit diesem Dungeon- und Dragon-Flare gemischt hat. Er erkannte diese Rollenspiele, die man mit Papier und Bleistift spielt. Und das wollte auf dem Graben. Ich finde auch immer noch, dass diese Text-Adventure mehr eine Atmosphäre rüberbringen, als später diese Grafik-Adventure von Lucas Films. Ich fand das albern, dass die überhaupt keine vollständigen Sätze mehr verstanden und alles kindgerecht vorgemalt war. Bei diesen Text-Adventure-Geschichten entstand durch diesen Text so ein eigenes Universum im Kopf beim Lesen, etwas vom Radio.
Der Computer wehrte sich auch noch so ein bisschen gegen den Benutzer. Willst du die Tür wirklich öffnen?
Ja, ich muss auch sagen, ich bin hier Infocom geprägt. Die ganze Talk-Reihe ist ja sogar noch mal als Graphik-Revival gekommen, wo du es noch mal so mistmäßig durchspielen konntest. Revisit, Flood Control, Dam 3 und all solche Geschichten, das gab es noch mal. Aber das war so geil, wenn man in irgendeinen Raum kam, und dann standen erst mal so die Standardsachen wie dieser Raum hat zwei Türen, eine im Osten, eine im Westen, in der rechten Ecke steht auch ein Schaufel, und in der linken Ecke steht ein Troll mit einem 4 Meter langen Stab in der Hand. Und dann dachte man sich schon, Scheiße! Und dann, was sollte man dann machen? Das war dann so dieses, ist der vielleicht nett? Und dann hat man irgendwas gemacht, und dann hatte man sofort einen drauf. Man musste sich auch noch die Karte selber zeichnen, das kann sich da heute keiner mehr vorstellen. Dass man dann sich merken musste, was wo liegt und so.
Ja, und war halt alles komplett auf Englisch. Und man selber vielleicht gerade mal zwei Jahre Englisch in der Schule gelernt. Und war dann nochmal eine extra Herausforderung. Überhaupt waren Spiele irgendwie immer eigentlich eine Herausforderung für die Leute, die irgendwie so jünger da rangekommen sind. Weil, ja wenn man ehrlich ist, hat man gerade auf dem C64 viele Spiele so auch als Kreditkopie gehabt. Jetzt mal kopieren und später vielleicht bezahlen. Und da war dann irgendwie ein Reiz des Spiels auch immer, wohnen geht's hier eigentlich?
Wie steuer ich das Ding?
Was ist das hier, was ich hier mache? Alles auf Englisch?
Und ich denke, das sind doch wirklich Sachen, die im Nachhinein genutzt haben. Wenn man dann von einer komplizierten Anwendung sitzt, dann weiß man einfach, na klar, ich klick das einfach alles durch und dann weiß ich, wie das Ding funktioniert. Also wirklich Übertragung, glaube ich, von Wissen.
Ja, also Elite war zum Beispiel ein Hammer, ne? Bis man verstanden hat, wie diese Sternenkarte funktionierte.
Wissen wir, dieses Raumschiff angedockt bekam. Ich habe da allerdings, muss ich gestehen, geschummelt. Ich hatte dann ganz schnell den Autopiloten.
Aber findet ihr, dass Computerspiele mittlerweile diese Art von Anspruch verloren haben?
Ich glaube, es ist irgendwie auch so eine Generationenfrage. Also wenn ich mich heutzutage mit so jüngeren Unterhalte aus der Generation Aldi-PC und dann Counter-Strike drauf oder so was, die sprechen eine andere Sprache und die sind irgendwie ganz anders geprägt durch ganz andere Spiele.
Aber die wissen schon, wie man den neuesten Grafik-Treiber installiert in den meisten Fällen. Das ist schon faszinierend. Also da wird schon ein bisschen drumherum erworben, finde ich.
Also man musste sich früher ja auch immer vor den Eltern rechtfertigen. Man musste immer sagen, ich kaufe mir das zum Vokabellernen mit einem Computer.
Denkt an die Zukunft.
Ich werde damit programmieren lernen und ich werde dann steinreich werden. Eigentlich wollte man halt nur spielen. Das war klar. Aber man musste das den Eltern ja gegenüber den Geldgebern irgendwie verkaufen. Und aus dem Grunde hat man dann halt irgendwie so ein Gebäude an Ausreden irgendwie aufgebaut. Aber es stimmt eigentlich. Also die Installation von dem Spiel irgendwie, die Interaktion mit dem Computer, man hat letztendlich dann doch was fürs Leben gelernt für die Computer-Benutzung.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gelernt, dass ich bei meinem Vater besser immer so gespielt habe, dass ich das rechte Knie immer, weil mein Computer so stand, auf der Reset-Taste hatte. Die hatte ich quasi reingedrückt beim Spielen. Und sobald der an die Türe kam, stand ich auf, der Reset-Knopf kam rausgesprungen, und der Computer machte... Das war natürlich so laut und hat so lange gedauert, dass er immer wusste, dass ich gerade gespielt habe, aber er wusste nicht was. Und weil Doom hätte ich ihm schlecht mit Vokabellern erklären können. Und so, das ist halt universell, sagen wir mal. Non-verbale Kommunikation. Aber kommen wir doch mal zu den Hörern zurück. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen unter 031 70 97 1 1 0. Die Chronologie wird hier noch weiter fortgeführt werden im Laufe des Chaosradio Blue Moons. Und am Telefon ist erstmal der Thorsten. Hallo Thorsten? Thorsten, du bist ja mit einer Derben-Behauptung unterwegs.
Ja, ich habe die Derbe-Behauptung, dass man Dune I, dieses wirklich uralt Rollenspiel, wirklich zu Ende spielen kann. Also das war folgendermaßen aufgebaut. Man durfte da einfach nicht zu schnell vorgehen, weil das hatte das System, dass nach einer Weile immer mehr Spies, also das Brunnen der alten Spies verlangt wurde von seinem Imperator. Wenn man aber zu früh halt angefangen hat, die Gegend zu erkunden, hat dieser Imperator halt zu früh diese Lieferung und das so weiter und so fort angefordert und da kam er nach einer Weile nicht mehr daher. Das war der erste Stolperstein. Und dieses Wasser, was man brauchte, um den, diesen hier Arakes zu begrünen, das hat sich in diesem Cistern auch mit der Zeit angesammelt. Und wenn man halt zu früh angefangen hat, diesen Garten, diesen versteckten Garten zu suchen und zu finden und dann halt diesen, naja halt Arakes da grün zu machen, dann hat man es halt auch noch eine Weile nicht mehr geschafft, weil halt die Vorräte zu kurz waren und zu knapp waren. Und das eigentliche Ende war, dass man diesen, den, den, den, na sag ich schon, den Palast von den... Harkonen, genau, den Palast Harkonen, den musste man dann angreifen nach einer ganzen Weile. Man hat da jede Menge Frim-Stämme befreit, die von den Harkonen unterjocht wurden und man hat da unterwegs Spice Harvester und Onythopter und Atomwaffen und dergleichen gefunden. Und ganz zum Schluss, das hatte dann schon gar nichts mehr mit der Begrünung des Planeten zu tun, musste man dann halt diesen Harkonen-Palast angreifen, wenn alles rundrum schon mit einem gehört hat.
Und das ging nicht?
Das ging, da musste man dann halt mit diesen Atomwaffen, die man da gefunden hat, meine Palasten angreifen. Wenn man wirklich alles rund... Es war eigentlich nur so ein, naja, so ein kleines... Also wirklich, es war wie Schach am Computer. Man hat eigentlich nur Figuren versetzt. Und jetzt eigentlich mit Spannung nicht so richtig verbunden.
In den Romanen von Frank Herbert klappt das ja eigentlich ganz gut mit dem Planeten und dem Spice. Gibt es denn irgendwie Menschen da draußen, die behaupten, natürlich konnte man die Unen lösen? Also du sagst, es ist nicht möglich.
Man kann die Unen auf jeden Fall lösen. Ich hab's durchgespielt. Ich hab dann am Ende im Hakon-Palast gestanden, als Paul Ottoides und war dann Imperator. Also ich hab Shaddam, den vierten oder wie er war, hab ich dann in die ewigen Spicebunde gejagt und der durfte dann irgendwo Sandtonnerzählen gehen. Also ich hab's durchgespielt. Auch jetzt vor drei Jahren glaube ich erst, auf unserem Dorf und so weiter. Weil es mir irgendwie mal in die Finger gekommen ist. Ich bin ja halt von der Dune-Reihe sowieso ziemlich fasziniert. Da dachte ich mir, tippe dich mal rein. Man muss da gedanklich ein paar Gänge zurückscheiden, um halt wieder hinzukommen.
Gut, also wir können jetzt sagen, alle in Berlin und Brandenburg und auf dem Rest der Welt, ihr könnt aufhören, man kann das Spiel. Zu Ende spielen, Thorsten aus Bautzen hat es geschafft. Danke, Thorsten. Gott sei Dank gibt es das auch als Film, weil sonst hätte man jetzt überhaupt nichts mehr verstanden. Nur die drei, die sich in Dune so weit reingespielt haben, das sind jetzt ein Harkon.
Aber man muss die acht Bücher schon gelesen haben. Das ist Science-Fiction-Klassiker.
Die kann man in der Regel bei seinem Antiquar kaufen. Ich hatte nämlich auch so einen. Und der wollte mir auf Teufelkommen raus nicht einen Band verkaufen, weil er, und das hatte er natürlich recht gehabt, eher die anderen Bände nicht mehr los wird. Also musste ich mir die auch komplett kaufen. Aber das ist ein anderes Buch. Und wir machen jetzt erst mal das Nachrichtenbuch drauf.
Exklusiven Fritz-Radio-Computer. Flut kommt und spielt ein exklusives Fritz-Studio-Konzert. Exklusiver jettet nicht. Und du kannst live dabei sein. Karten, die es live in den Fritz-Studios gibt, nirgendwo zu kaufen, sondern nur per SMS an Fritz.
017 090 26 8 Kennwort Schlampe.
Und wenn dich dann unsere Glücksschlampe zieht, bist du live dabei und im Radio Fritz, das nur als Periphera-Hinweis. Wenn frisch, dann 91, 9 23 Uhr 32 Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter, nachts wechselnd bewölkt und abklingende Schauer bei 21 bis 16 Grad, morgen anfangs noch heiter, später teils kräftige Gewitter bei 23 bis 27 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Berner.
Die PDR-Spitze hat den Rückzug ihres vorigen Parteichefs Gysi von allen politischen Ämtern bedauert. Die Vorsitzende Zimmerzollte Gysi Respekt bezeichnete seine Entscheidung aber als überzogen. Gysi war heute als Berliner Wirtschaftssenator und Bürgermeister zurückgetreten. Er legte auch sein Abgeordnetenhausmandat nieder. Für morgen ist eine Sonderansetzung des Senats geplant. Bundestagspräsident Thierse hat der Lufthansa in der Bonus-Main-Affäre ein Ultimatum gestellt. In einem Brief forderte er bis morgen Nachmittag eine Liste der Abgeordneten, die mit Bonus-Main geflogen sind. Thierse erklärte, dass die von der Bild-Zeitung verwendeten Daten nur von der Lufthansa stammen könnten. In der Türkei finden am 3. November vorgezogene Parlamentswahlen statt. Das entschied das Parlament bei einer Sondersetzung in Ankara. Die Wahlen sollen nach wochenlanger Unsicherheit wegen der angeschlagenen Gesundheit von Ministerpräsident Eşeviç wieder zu politischer Stabilität führen. Bei einem Bombenanschlag auf die Universität von Jerusalem sind sieben Menschen getötet und mehr als 85 verletzt worden. Der Sprengsatz explodierte in der Cafeteria des Internationalen Studentenzentrums. Zu der Tat bekannte sich die radikale islamische Hamas-Organisation. Und zum Sport bei den Schwimm-Europameisterschaften hat Franziska van Allenseeck den Titel über 100 Meter Freistier gewonnen. In der Staffel von Anzig war es nach 2 Siegen in der Staffel bereits die 3. Goldmedaille bei dem Titelkämpfen.
Und im Radio gibt's Freikarten.
Und bevor wir beim Chaosradio weitermachen, möchten wir die DJen, die wir hier zu Gast haben, noch mal ordentlich würdigen. Das ist Ellen, die legt gerade die Platte auf, die nun auch richtig fit und crisp anfangen soll. Wir warten einfach noch eine Sekunde und ihr könnt, wenn ihr Lust habt, solange auf jeden Fall eine Mail schreiben, an 74s-chaosradio.ccc.de. Na ja, dann warten wir eben noch fünf Millisekunden. Nee, die Platte ist zerkratzt. Dann quatschen wir erst mal ein bisschen. Das müssen wir auch mal möglich sein. Der Jens und der Mario sind im Studio vom Chaos Computer Club Köln und machen heute Abend Chaos Radio hier auf Fritz. Mein Name ist Max von Malodki und es geht um Spiele. Und dann machen wir doch direkt weiter mit euch. Dune kann man zu Ende spielen, das haben wir vorhin erfahren. Und jetzt gucken wir erstmal, was der Maurice zu erzählen hat.
Ja, ich habe eine lustige Geschichte zu dem Tennisspiel, über das ihr die ganze Zeit geredet habt.
Dieser Atari-Klassiker.
Und zwar, wenn ich im Osten groß geworden bin, und da gab es ja keine Tomaten, Buden und Videospiele. Und war mit meinen Eltern dann mal in Polen, in Sakopan im Urlaub.
Da war ich so zwölf.
Also das war so 78, 79.
Und da habe ich das erste Mal so einen Teil gesehen.
Und da haben wir natürlich in das Haschengeld mit wachsender Begeisterung reingestopft. Und das kostete damals nach fünf Swati. Und mein letztes fünf Swati Stück fiel mir durch den Gitterruss dieser Bude. Und ich bin da runtergekrabbelt und fand einen Haufen gefeilte Kupfermünzen. Also die Polen waren da ganz pfiffig und hatten sich selber die fünf Swati-Stücken aus Kupferstücken gefeilt. Und wir haben dann die ganzen Namen dann auch umsonst gespielt. Das fand ich echt richtig stark.
Cool, da fällt mir diese Geschichte ein von den beiden Jungen in Amerika mit den Automaten. Da war dieser Automat, da wurden Spiele gezählt. Da war aber kein Geld im Schacht. Im Schacht war nur Wasser und Dreck. Und irgendwann hat der Besitzer sich auf die Lauer gelegt. Und dann kamen die beiden Jungen vorbei mit so einer Kühlbox auf einem Bollerwagen. Da drin hatten die gefrorenen Wasserscheiben, die sie mit Sand gemischt hatten, damit das Gewicht stimmt.
Ja, der war zum Polen.
Und dann wollte ich nur sagen, dass es auf dem Mac, damals zur Mac 2 noch ein gutes Spiel gab, dass wir mit wachsender Begeisterung in der Grafikstudie spielten, und zwar Wolf 3D. Ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt das ein Begriff ist.
Hat das was mit Wolfenstein 3D zu tun?
Ja, genau, man rannte da als russischer Agent durch irgendwelche Hütte, ist leider abgelümpft und hat die Nazis niedergemacht und die Schätze gefunden.
Ich glaube, es war kein russischer Agent. Es war, glaube ich, ein Amerikaner. War auf jeden Fall eins dieser ersten Ego-Shooter. War auch irgendwie super heftig in der Situation in Deutschland, weil es irgendwie einerseits höllenmäßig brutal war und dann irgendwie diese ganze eBay-Symbolik in Deutschland dann irgendwie... Ja, das ging so nicht. Ich habe mir auch sagen lassen, dass es sehr lustig ist.
Also ich habe da Kopfschmerzen von gekriegt.
Ja, man wird vielleicht sehkrank bei diesen Ego-Shooter, ne?
Das war sehr, sehr anstrengend. Aber ich fand die Ausrufe ganz schön. Ich bin ja, das ist vielleicht die Sache beim Radio, so ein bisschen akustophil, aber die haben halt immer so auf Amerikanisch-Deutsch geschrien, wenn es denen am Kragen ging. Dann haben die immer geschrien, mein Leben, mein Leben!
Ja, genau. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mal zu Ende gespielt hast, aber also richtig schön fand ich die Szene. Am Schluss hatte man natürlich als Endgätegegner das Böse selber, irgendwie Adolf Hitler, in einer Ritterrüstung. Und wenn man den dann auch noch niedergemacht hat, verabschiedete er sich mit den Worten, oh Eva, auf Wiedersehen.
Und ja, man muss dazu sagen, bevor jetzt alle denken, oh Mann, wie reden die denn über so hart indizierte Spiele, über die man eigentlich gar nicht reden sollte, man muss sagen, dass das, wenn man den nötigen Abstand hat und sich davon nicht beeinflussen lässt, dass solche Symbole, und das ist bei uns so, auch nicht benutzt werden dürfen, war es wirklich sehr lustig.
Es war ja ein Antifa-Spiel. Man musste ja Nazis abknallen.
Ich fand's eigentlich nicht besonders. Dat hätte man sich sparen können mit den Symbolen, aber mir egal.
Na gut, die Amis haben da nicht so ein Problem mit Grasch, ne? War halt nur ein Spiel. Aber am Telefon ist der Holger.
Guten Abend.
Was hast du beizutragen zur Diskussion heute Abend beim Chaosradio?
Ja, ich kann was sagen für der Akkadenkultur, die es hier angeblich nicht gab. Also ich bin 33 und hab mit 12, 13, Anfang der 80er, durchaus in so Snackbars und so Rolling-Bahnen abgehangen und solche Spiele gespielt. Wobei ich im Nachhinein wirklich sagen muss, also klar, jetzt kann ich drüber lachen, aber ich finde nicht, dass man da von der Kultur reden kann. Also ich glaube, man kann sich als 12-Jähriger eine bessere Nachmittagsgestaltung vorstellen.
Wirklich? Also, ja, man könnte irgendwie ins Kaufhaus gehen und da irgendwie sehnsuchtsvoll auf die Heimcomputer starren. Aber das war ungefähr so die Nachmittagsgestaltung eines westdeutschen Nerds. Entweder man hing irgendwo ab, wo es Akkadenspiele gab oder war halt im Kaufhaus und hat da irgendwie 10 Print-Hallore, 20 Coto 10 eingegeben.
Ja, das war hier nicht anders. Also ich bin aus Berlin und wir haben dann da immer in so einer ziemlich miesen Spelunke gehangen, wo wir wahrscheinlich gar nicht rein durften vom Alter her. Und ich kann mich erinnern, Phoenix und Scramble waren die beiden Automaten, die da jahrelang standen und die wir da bis zum Abwinken gespielt haben.
Kann ich mich nicht mehr genau dran erinnern.
Das ist ein bisschen ähnlich wie Defender, ja genau. Du fliegst durch so eine Kraterlandschaft und kommst so Feuerbälle entgegen. Man muss so Sachen abschießen und einsammeln.
Aber lass mich raten, das Scrawling war butterweich.
Jaja, klar.
Nein, nein, das war nicht Amiga.
Sekunde, Sekunde, Sekunde. Es gibt hier zwei Arten von diesen Shootern. Ich weiß nämlich nicht mehr, ob Scramble jetzt das war, was ich im Gedächtnis habe. War das einer, wo es von links nach rechts geht?
Genau.
Oder ja, so einer.
Da stiegen immer so Raketen hoch. Und den muss man ausweichen. Die konnte man aber auch mit Bomben abwerfen oder abschießen.
Weil es gab nämlich auch eine, die kam dann später, wo man im Grunde so schräg nach vorne geflogen ist, so schräg oben rechts in die Bildschirm-Ecke und dann auch immer die Ebenheiten mitgenommen hat und so Sachen durchfliegen konnte und so.
Nee, nee, das war es nicht. Das war auch relativ langsam überschaubar. Und es ging relativ lange. Also man musste ja eine Mark reinstecken, was in dem Alter auch ziemlich viel Geld war. Und da konnte man, wenn man es ein bisschen konnte, relativ lang mitspielen. Und wir haben dann auch so Methoden entwickelt, wie man es billiger spielen konnte.
Kann ich ja jetzt ruhig erzählen. Es gab insbesondere zwei Methoden.
Das eine nannte sich schnippen und das andere schocken.
Schnippen war so die Software-Variante.
Da hat man, anstatt das Geld oben reinzustecken, fennig und zweifennig Stücke von unten so ein bisschen gefühlvoll in diesen Schacht reingeschnippt, durch den das Geld wieder rauskam, wenn das nicht funktioniert hat. Und die haben dann irgendeinen Kontakt berührt und dadurch hatte man dann Credit auf dem Spiel. Das ist ja geil. Und das hatten wir irgendwann so drauf, dass es so schnell ging, wie eine Mark oben reinschmeißen. Man konnte dann halt nur irgendwann, musste man die Location wechseln, weil man sich dachte, irgendwann lernen die ja auch mal diesen Automaten und wundern sich dann wahrscheinlich, wenn da lauter Fennekstücke drin rumliegen. Und das andere war dann schockend, eine Zeit, wo dann jeder von uns, der was aus sich hielt, mit so einem Herdgasanzünder rumlief. Und den hielt man da irgendwo an so einem Metallteil und drückte da drauf. Und das war dann immer eine Überraschung, ob dann einer oder 20 Credits drauf kamen oder plötzlich einfach einen lauten Ton gab und das Ding ausging. Und dann ist man ziemlich schnell da rausgegangen. Also wie gesagt, wenn ich das im Nachhinein betrachte, denke ich, ich hätte lieber ein Musikinstrument lernen sollen.
Ich denke, du hast deine Zeit genau richtig investiert.
Dann kannst du die Geschichte hier auch nicht erzählen. Was würde dann passieren? Da würden wir hier sitzen und Däumchen drehen.
Das ist wahr, ja. Ach klar, wenn man da jetzt im Nachhinein dran denkt. So sehr lustig.
Man sagt Atari auch nach, dass sie damals bei ihren Automaten ganze Entwicklungsabteilungen damit beschäftigt haben, die Teile abzuschieben vor eben solchen Tricks.
In der Entwicklungsabteilung bin ich aber gerne gewesen, weil die hatten bestimmt einen, der immer allen möglichen Scheiß ausprobieren musste. Ich gehe da mal mit Essen ran jetzt.
Aber bei Atari, das müsste sowieso eine wunderbare Zeit gewesen sein.
Ja, also Entwicklungs... Also es gab einen Geldgeber von Atari, der gesagt hat, wenn ich in die Bude reingehe, dann halte ich die Luft an und erst wenn ich wieder rauskomme, dann atme ich wieder aus, weil irgendwie das ganze Gebäude muss wohl irgendwie mit THC-haltigen Harzen durchflutet gewesen sein. Es gibt so eine hübsche Geschichte, dass irgendwann mal so ein Business-Meeting war. Atari, damals irgendwie wirklich milliardenschweres Unternehmen. Und irgendwie man traf sich mit Geschäftspartnern, der Geschäftsführer von Atari, Nolan Baschnell, irgendwie im Batik-T-Shirt und Jeans, alle anderen irgendwie auch und auf der anderen Seite halt die Leute mit den Anzügen und mit den Krawatten. Man guckte sich irgendwie betreten an und um da irgendwie die Spannung aus der Situation zu nehmen, hat Nolan Baschnell gesagt, ja mach mal eine Rundreise durch unsere Fertigungsstraße, hat irgendwie die Geschäftspartner in Kartons gepackt und die wurden dann irgendwie über die Fließbänder geschickt und haben sich dann irgendwie angesehen, wie die Hippies da irgendwie die Automaten zusammengebaut haben. Und am Abend gab es dann nochmal ein Geschäftsessen, da hat sich Atari gedacht, wir zeigen es dann doch, dass wir es auch drauf haben, ist in Anzügen geschäftsmäßig dann aufgetreten. Mittlerweile hat aber der Geschäftspartner gedacht, ne ne, wir müssen uns da anpassen und die kamen dann in T-Shirts und T-Shirts.
Das alles war vor 1976, da wurde nämlich Atari für 28 Millionen Dollar an Warner verkauft.
Ja und dann änderte sich auch irgendwie so die Kultur bei Atari irgendwie extremst.
Ja vorher, wenn die ein Ingenieur wollten, haben die glaub ich gesagt, komm zu uns, wir haben Bio und Worldpools und ab und zu springen die Sekretärinnen rein. Hört man, hört man.
Holger, da kannst du mal sehen, womit du oder was du zerstört hast, indem du da immer Fenige von unten reingeschnipst hast.
Ja, das war nicht selber Schuld, die Leute bei Atari, da fehlt die Innovation.
Das weiß nicht der Holger alleine, stimmt schon. Ach, herrlich, herrlich. Ich finde es toll, dass der Holger angerufen hat, weil solche Geschichten, sowas muss man echt erleben, sowas kann man ja nicht simulieren. Wie soll man sowas auch wissen? Sowas steht auch nicht im Internet, weil da schreibt ja aus Angst schon wieder keiner auf. Oh, schlechte Telefonleitung, aber vielleicht eine gute Geschichte. Nee, erzähl mal, worum geht es bei dir? Du bist wahrscheinlich noch bei deinem ersten Spiel zugangen, das, was du als erstes gespielt hast.
Ja, also wirklich, dann an meinem eigenen Computer, den ich damals bekommen habe, Indiana Jones, in Zufahrt auf Atlantis, also Adventure von LucasArts. Und das war dann auch so die Schiene, wo ich dann die nächsten Jahre darauf geblieben bin, bei den Adventures, also wie gesagt, eine ganze Monkey Island Reihe. Und irgendwie, naja, sah das dann, also alle Adventures von denen sahen auch so ziemlich gleich aus. Wurden bloß, ähm, wie später raus kam, ein bisschen bunter. Und ja, und irgendwann wurde auch dieses Inventar animiert. Ja, und ja, Adventure, also das habe ich damals so gespielt.
Die hatten auch noch Humor damals.
Ja, also die Monkey Island Reihe, das ist ja wirklich genial mit dem Humor. Und aber trotzdem war das alles noch so, wie soll man sagen, so ein bisschen piratenmäßig gemacht eben. Also dass man sich dann noch so in diese Zeit versetzt hatte. Und ja, man hat auch eine gute Atmosphäre in den Spielen. Und ja, ich hatte auch mal Loom probiert.
Ja, Loom wird immer angeführt. Dabei habe ich das nicht so richtig empfohlen. Monkey Island fand ich mal besser.
Aber Loom habe ich auf alle Fälle gar nicht verstanden, weil man da irgendwie immer diese Töne spielen musste.
Ja, genau, da waren so komische Rätselspiele drin, fand ich auch.
Ja, da bin ich nie vor, nie weiterzukommen.
Ich habe nämlich auch kein Instrument gelernt.
Und ja, also mit Text-Adventuren, also habe ich eigentlich nie welche ausprobiert. Aber ja, wie gesagt, bei den alten Adventuren, da war die Atmosphäre noch ziemlich gut. Und jetzt bei den neuen, also von den Paaren, die noch rausgekommen sind, wie Mankerland 4 war glaube ich der letzte, ne? Und hier Grim Fandango, also ja, die waren schon gut, aber irgendwie haben die nicht mehr die Atmosphäre hingekriegt.
Hast du schon mal Anachronox gespielt? Das ist auf jeden Fall lustig.
Ja, wenn er das letzte was mir zuletzt bei Evil bestellt hatte, war sie dick gewesen. Das, was wir da auch mit Sieben Spielberg angeblich zusammen gemacht haben. Wo man da so, ja, mit diesen Meteroiden, und dann ist man da in so eine geheimnisvolle Welt gekommen. Mit so einem Space Shuttle. Das hatte ich dann zuletzt nochmal gespielt. Ja, naja, und jetzt soll ja dann eventuell noch demnächst hier auf Units Flucht 3 rauskommen, ne? Ja, bin ich ja mal gespannt, aber... Ja, also das Adventure in Angriff, was ich noch ziemlich gut fand, war The Riddle of Master Lu, kennt ihr das?
Hab ich nie gespielt, kenn ich aber vom Titel.
Ja, also da war die Atmosphäre ziemlich gut gewesen. Und ja, also, naja, wie gesagt, die Spiele hab ich dann auf meinem ersten PC gespielt, aber davor hatte ich dann bei einem Kumpel, der hatte zwei Amigas, und da haben wir auch eine Menge gespielt. Unter anderem war es, glaub ich, auch Wing Commander gewesen. Und hauptsächlich Street Fighter, weil ja, da waren wir darauf ausgelegt gewesen, dass wir welche dieser kleinen Kampfspielchen da gespielt haben.
Das ist ja auch wirklich ein Miteinanderspiel. Also klar, man spielt gegeneinander, aber man kann endlich mal interagieren, mit einem Menschen, nicht nur mit der Maschine, intelligente Gegner.
Genau, und dann hat er sich da noch massig Bücher gehört, wie dieses Special-Move-Skin, wo du die Finger verdreht hast, dass du an die ganzen Klöpfchen reinkommst, dass du dann da irgendwas, wie ich, so eine Supersense wirft oder einem das Genick bricht und so ein Scheiß.
Welche Figur hast du gespielt bei Street Fighter?
Ich hatte immer diesen Gully, hieß der, glaube ich, bei diesen Namen-Klamotten. Und der hatte dann immer noch so eine bekloppte Version, wo dann immer noch irgendwelche Grafik-Fehlerchen waren, wo man die unteren Beine nicht gesehen hat. Das war dann einfach nur so ein Block, aus wenigereren Farben bestehend. Die waren dann immer ein bisschen fehlerhaft gewesen. Ja, das war aber schon, wie gesagt, lustig gewesen.
Also bei Streetfighter war ja irgendwie besonders die Frauen, die waren viel viel cooler als die Männer. Also Chun Li zum Beispiel, die Chinesen.
Das war halt die Schnellste.
Ja, die mit diesem blauen Kleid, ne?
Ja, mit diesem Helikopter-Move, mit dem Daim.
Genau, ja, mit dem hat sich auch drauf.
Mit dem Gulli und diesem Blitz, das ich machen konnte. Das waren so die eins in drei gewesen, die ich wirklich beherrscht habe. Du hast vorhin was mit dem Konfigurieren von Treiber installieren, von Spielen gesagt. Wie waren das damals so gewesen? Also wenn man heute diese Spiele spielt, da gibt es ja dann noch diese Tour-Zieh-versteckte Grafik-Features-Fresher, die Anti-Strop-Filtering, wo man die ganze Scheiße einstellen kann und Anti-Aliasing und sowas. Wie waren das damals so auf dem C64? Also ich kann mich nur bei einem Kumpel erinnern, der hatte einen 486, und da haben wir auch Monkey Island und Prince of Persia drauf gespielt. Und da brauchte man ein paar Bootesketten, damit das alles überhaupt an den Starten ging.
Ja, also es ist vielleicht doch eine andere Generation. Auf dem C64 hielt sich das mit der Installation von Grafiktreibern in sehr engen Grenzen. Final Cartridge, also es gab Zusatz-Hardware. Es gab diese coolen Dinge, wo man den Spielstand einfriessen konnte. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute über Spiele zur Assembler-Programmierung gekommen sind. Man hat sich halt irgendwie den Assembler-Dump, der im Speicher war, angeguckt, hat gesehen, Moment, irgendwo ist doch der Zähler, der immer hochläuft. Den finde ich jetzt, hat irgendwie den Speicher durchkempt und irgendwann hatte man den Zähler gefunden. Und wenn man den irgendwie auf eine beliebig lange Zahl von neunen oder so gesetzt hatte, hatte man irgendwie schier unendlich viele Leben und konnte endlich mal das Scheißspiel durchspielen.
Also auch die ersten Grafikkarten auf dem PC waren ja schon noch so einfach, dass man sie selber programmieren konnte mit Assembler. Da konnte man direkt reinschreiben. Da war noch nichts mit irgendwelchen Libraries, OpenGL, DirectX. Da konnte man also wirklich irgendwie noch selber dran. Dafür hat man andere Sachen gemacht, nur so Speicher optimieren mit irgendwelchen QEM-Tools und nur das letzte noch da irgendwie rausholen aus den 640K.
Ja, aber das sind letztendlich irgendwie alles Geschichten aus dem Kartoffelkrieg. Sei froh, dass du in einer Zeit lebst, wo du das nicht mehr erleben musstest.
Also in 1995, wo ich meinen ersten Rechner gekauft habe, das war Ende 1995, also ein Pentium mit 75 MHz, und da kam brandneue Windows 95 raus. Und ich hatte das Pech, das zu erwischen, und alle Spiele waren noch für DOS. Naja, und da hat man das unter Windows nicht richtig zu starken gekriegt, weil ich hatte immer das Soundproblem, der Sound ging nie, weil die immer irgendwelche DOS-Treiberchen brauchten. Ich hatte dann immer, wie gesagt, von meinem Freund, der Vater, der hat uns das dann immer eingerichtet, dass ich mit Sound spielen konnte, unter DOS, aber irgendwie nach zig neuen Installationen, weil Windows 95 doch noch nicht so ging, wie man sich das vorgestellt hatte, ging es dann irgendwie nicht. Und irgendwann habe ich dann herausgefunden, bei diesen Spielen von LucasArts war eben das Problem, da war kein Installationsdatei auf der Diskette, die waren schon so komplett drauf und du brauchst es einfach nur in einem Ordner kopieren, dass du die Spiele dann noch mit so einem Parameter wie S oder A starten musstest, für Soundblaster und A for Ad-Lib und so weiter.
Ich habe mein DOS auch lange verteidigt, aber irgendwann ging es nicht mehr an, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, war das Dungeon Keeper, da liefen die Spiele plötzlich nur noch unter Windows. Da musste ich natürlich auflusten.
Also ich fand DOS ziemlich scheiße mit dem ganzen Eintippen. Und ich fand Windows lustig, aber dass es eben mit dem Spiel nicht ging, das war nicht so besonders gut gewesen.
Ach, das Wort Kommandozeileninterpret ist aber eins, das ich mir eingeprägt habe mit zwölf Jahren, glaube ich. Und dann habe ich es nie wieder vergessen. Apropos Kommandozeileninterpret. Man kann ja hier anrufen unter 0377 110. Man kann aber auch kommandozeilenmäßig einfach Sachen im Chat hinterlassen. Und wir haben es tatsächlich jetzt geschafft, uns netzwerkmäßig hier so weit zu organisieren, dass ich das hier auch in Teilen vorlesen kann. Aber die Chats, die wir quasi überwachen mit unseren Wachenaugen, die hat der Mario auf dem Zettel stehen.
Hast du hier stehen.
Chatten, chatten. Ja, ja. Ich habe nämlich auf meinem Monitor leider keinen Chat. Dafür kann ich euch sagen, wo. irc.ccc.de im Channel Chaosradio. Dann gibt es noch den Fritz V-Chat. Wer IRC nicht mag, findet mal Hilfe unter www.fritz.de. Einfach mal nach Fritz V-Chat gucken. Und natürlich im Chaos V-Chat.
Da kann ich ein paar Stichworte vorlesen, damit das nicht alles so im Sande verläuft. Einfach noch mal ein paar Spiele, die der Jens aus Lörrach immer gespielt hat. Da haben wir teilweise was schon von gehabt. Arcade, Mrs. Pac-Man, wenn ich mich da jetzt nicht verlese. Atari 2600 Pac-Man. OEC 64, das kenne ich allerdings nicht. Zauberschloss, Grand Prix Circuit, eine Rennsimulation. Dann Ultima 1, das ist natürlich, da haben wir heute überhaupt noch nicht drüber gesprochen, was ich ja immer sehr sehr geil fand. Green Beret, auch sehr geil. Robocop, Colonization auf dem PC. Dann Doom, Castle Wolfenstein haben wir schon drüber gesprochen, Command & Conquer und Diablo als erstes Online-Game. Was ich allerdings sehr spannend finde, ein Hörer namens Cassandro hat als erstes Jugend-Forscht-Projekt, schreibt er in diesem Chat, ein Tic-Tac-Toe-spielendes neuronales Netzwerk aufgebaut. Das hört sich gut an, das ist ja wie in dem Film, wie hieß er nochmal? War Games. Ein Klassiker, weiß ich aber auch nicht mehr aus welchem Jahr der war.
Na ja klar, wenn der Computer gegen einen spielen soll, dann lässt man den am besten lernen. Ein Tic-Tac-Toe ist ein endliches Spiel, da benutzt man ein neuronales Netz. Das wird angelernt in den ersten paar Spielen und irgendwann ist es dann unschlagbar. Nein, bei Tic-Tac-Toe kommt es darauf an, wer zuerst zieht, der gewinnt, wenn er Intelligenz spielt. Auf die 3x3-Fläche.
Am Telefon ist der Marcel, hallo Marcel.
Hallo.
Was ist denn du für Geschichten mitgebracht aus deiner alten Computerzeit, die sich bis heute fortgesetzt hat?
Ja, das fing so mit Mami-Ga an, vielleicht erinnert sich doch jemand an Silkworm?
Kein Hoah, aber trotzdem bestimmt toll, ja.
Da spricht der Atari-User eben mehr. Nee, das war es schon.
C64 habe ich auch noch zwei unter mir stehen. Jo, ich möchte ein bisschen Werbung machen, und zwar für ein Unix-Projekt.
Toll, bin ich dabei.
Ich kann euch aber nicht helfen. Wenn Sie es nicht wissen, erinnert sich jemand an ein älteres DOS-Spiel, das Solar-Vines. Da hat man ein kleines Raumschiff geflogen, ein bisschen gehandelt, ein bisschen Leute abgedingelt. Und da gibt es jetzt auch ein freies Projekt seit 5, 6, 7 Jahren. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so historisch, aber ist trotzdem lustig. Wenn man mal auf Google geht und da mal X-Ship Wars gibt, dann kommt man auf die GPL-Seite, kann sich das runterladen, kompilieren und kann sich dann in gewisse Universen teilhaben.
Und spiele ich dann nur mit Leuten zusammen, die selber das Kompilieren beherrschen? Das ist ja das Lustige.
Du spielst wirklich nur mit Leuten, die es zumindest mal schaffen, GCC zu bedienen. Die zumindest mal Configure und Make-up rufen können. Das steigert das Niveau dann doch schon ein bisschen.
Okay, ich wäre schon mal nicht dabei.
Ich wäre dabei. Es gibt irgendwie auch relativ wenig Spiele unter Unix, Linux etc.
Also gibt es schon eine Menge Spiele.
Gerade so bei mir, ich habe hier eine Alpha stehen und da gibt es nicht mal einen brauchbaren Doom-Part und Quake läuft auch nicht so wirklich. Und da habe ich auf der Suche, was läuft denn so auf der Kiste?
NetHack. NetHack läuft auf jeden Fall.
Aber das ist ja nicht Multiplayer.
Nee, ist aber ein Spiel, was ich hier noch super fesselnd finde, auch wenn es da mittlerweile eine grafische Version von gibt. Ich glaube, sie heißt Diablo. Hawken's Eye, ja.
Ja, es gibt zwei, drei davon.
Also für mich muss die Spielerfigur aus einem Ed-Zeichen bestehen und ich muss, wenn ich einen Doppelpunkt sehe, wissen, dass es dann eine Futration ist.
Das sind die Macintosh User. Macintosh?
NetHack ist ja auch schon 25 Jahre alt oder so.
Also der Vorgänger von NetHack ist sogar noch eine Spur witziger, finde ich.
Das läuft auch auf deinem Palm, ne? Das sieht ja schon gut aus, die Screenshots von X-Shit-Bores. Da hat sich ja schon einiges getan. Das ist ja schon richtig bunt.
Es gibt da eine stabile Version, 1.3.4. Wobei ich musste da ein bisschen drehen. Ich musste Optimization rausnehmen, also Minus O6 auskommentieren und halt Minus G für die Bugs-Symbols hinten dran.
Nee, ist klar, hätte ich auch so gemacht.
Naja, dann kam auch ein GDB drauf und dann sieht man auch, warum es dann damit abstürzt. Dann findet man raus, dass es die Map ist und dann patcht man ein bisschen rum und läuft dann auch irgendwann.
Nee, mach das mal so, dass es nicht mehr abstürzt.
Dann sag zum Abschluss nochmal dieses Projekt, ich glaube es wird keinem wehtun und dann werden die zwei, die das verstehen und die tatsächlich da auch mitmachen können, sich auch da mal melden. Sag nochmal kurz die Netzadresse.
Oh, die ist ein bisschen länger.
Ich habe es zusammen geschrieben bei Google.
Wollen wir die Leute nochmal Daten raten lassen?
Ja, spielen. Daten raten, da sollte man vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, was das ist. Grundsätzlich hört ihr das Chaosradio auf Fritz im Blue Moon und wir haben gleich noch ungefähr eine Stunde Zeit. Es geht grob um Spiele und Daten raten ist eigentlich ganz ganz knifflig, Jens.
Ja, ihr hört gleich eine klassische Computer- Melodie.
Kennt ihr bestimmt.
Kennt ihr auf jeden Fall, habt ihr auf dem C64 stundenlang schon gehört. Ist natürlich, also ganz, ganz naturbelassen, also wird in der Form abgespielt, wie es auch auf dem C64 zu hören war. Und wenn ihr wisst, um welche Melodie oder um welches Spiel es sich handelt, solltet ihr anrufen und könnt attraktive Preise gewinnen. Nämlich ein Paket der letzten 5 Datenschleudern, die Zeitschrift des Chaos Computer Clubs.
So, jetzt müssen wir uns natürlich nur, um auch den Schwierigkeitsgrad festzulegen, für einen Track auf dieser wunderbaren CD entscheiden.
Ich würde sagen Nummer 9 ist nicht ganz außer, doch ist vom C64, ist aber vielleicht ein bisschen leichter, weil es schon mehrmals heute Abend genannt wurde.
Also die Nummer 9. Und das ist ja auch gleichzeitig schon ein Tipp, dass es schon mal genannt wurde, ist allerdings auch sehr verwirrend, weil ungefähr tausend Sachen heute Abend schon genannt wurden.
Das ist nicht...
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt noch ein Toc. Ja, ich hatte verloren. Also, ja, also 03317797110 ist die Nummer und ihr könnt wild raten, solltet ihr das aber mit, naja, mit etwas in Konzentration tun. Ja, um welches Spiel handelt das sich da? Das ist ein C64 Spiel und es gibt es aber auch auf anderen Systemen noch. Es hat mehrere Fortsetzungen davon gegeben, das verrät nicht zu viel, wenn wir das so sagen. Für welches Spiel ist das die Titelmelodie? 03-77-97-1-1-0. Und da tue ich doch einfach mal so an, wüsste nicht, dass der Marcel das weiß, dann nehmen wir den Marcel. Marcel, was ist das für ein Spiel? Entschuldigung, dass ich so ein bisschen die Spannung genommen habe, aber... Marcel, selber gespielt Monkey Island?
Ja, früher gespielt.
Welche Teile denn, den ersten und alle und so?
Den ersten und den zweiten.
Marcel, bist du ein Kenner?
Marcel?
Das passiert manchmal. Das sind atmosphärische Störungen. Wenn die NSA aufhört, uns abzuhören, dann sind die Hörer weg. Marcel, du wirst uns wahrscheinlich über das Radio noch empfangen. Ruf doch einfach nochmal an, die zwei, drei, vier, fünf Datenschleudern. Die letzten fünf Ausgaben sind ja auf jeden Fall sicher. Muss uns nicht böse sein. NSA ist übrigens die National Security Agency. Da wir jetzt ganz, ganz, ganz viele Hörer haben, die hier warten, im Grunde ihren Beitrag zu leisten zur Sendung, würde ich sagen, wir arbeiten erstmal alles ab, was hier an Themen ansteht und dann spielen wir nochmal.
Also auch noch nicht direkt noch einen?
Das können wir gerne tun. Allerdings ist die Gefahr, dass ich dann den Überblick verliere, so ein bisschen groß, aber machen wir es ruhig. Welchen Titel wollen wir denn spielen?
Ich würde gerne Nummer 14 hören.
Auch machbar.
Ist das nicht die Russische. Nein. Aber das ist auch schon klar, weil die Iris weiß Bescheid. Hallo Iris.
Hallo Iris.
Toll, das ist ein Event. Wir müssen warten. Wir müssen hier ein kleines Kreuz machen. Das ist die erste junge Dame heute Abend. Was für ein Spiel ist das, zu dem wir da die Melodie gehört haben?
Summer Games.
Viel gespielt?
Überhaupt nicht.
Nee, aber mein Freund.
Da bestätigen sich Vorurteile.
Also dein Freund hat es dir vorgesagt und du hast nur angerufen, dachtest irgendwie, den Frauenbonus kommst du durch.
Nee, genau.
Er ist auch im Telefon.
Aber ich hab auch immer gespielt.
Also andere Sachen, ja.
Darfst ihn auch mal lesen lassen. In den fünf Ausgaben.
Viel Spaß damit, Iris. Und das war nicht der Frauenbonus, du warst tatsächlich die Erste, die angerufen hat. Danke, tschüss und viel Spaß damit. Danke, tschüss. Wollen wir nochmal spielen? Ja.
Nummer vier?
Hatten wir Nummer vier nicht vorhin?
Nee, hatten wir nicht.
Kann ich bitte hören, dass es machbar sein könnte?
Es ist machbar.
Welches Spiel handelt es sich da? Ja, und da wird es dann richtig, richtig anstrengend. Und da wird es dann in dem Spiel auch meistens ziemlich schwer, sobald die Musik so weit fortgeschritten war. Worum handelt es sich da? Müssen wir mal ganz kurz schauen. 031-77-97-1-1-0 ist die Nummer, wenn ihr das erkannt haben solltet. Und, na, probieren wir doch einfach mal den Axel. Vielleicht weiß der Axel es ja. Das war insofern eine Herausforderung, als du gar nicht konkret dafür angerufen hast, sondern zum anderen Spiel was beizutragen hattest. Bist du denn trotzdem froh, dass du jetzt fünf Ausgaben der Datenschleuder gewonnen hast?
Ähm, um ehrlich zu sein, ihr habt grad Iris rausgeschmissen.
Wir haben grad Iris rausgeschmissen? Echt? Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist heute ein bisschen strange, alles mit der Telefonanlage, aber wenn die Iris noch neben dir ist und das sozusagen das kollektive Netzwerk ist, dann ist das ja eigentlich gar kein Problem.
Nee, wir brauchen sowieso nur eine Ausgabe.
Ja, wisst aber so viel. Also wollt ihr nicht vielleicht noch eine CD haben?
Gerne.
Machen wir das so, irgendwie fünf Ausgaben Datenschleuder und eine Chaos-CD mit den Gesamtausgaben zum Durchforsten. Alles klar.
Aber Axel, warum rufst du eigentlich an?
Ich ruf an, weil ich eine Geschichte erzählen wollte mit einem alten Spiel, nämlich Bubbleboppel, falls das irgendjemand kennt.
Ja, Track 2, vielleicht als Hintergrundmusik?
Kein Problem. Moment, bin gleich soweit.
Ja, genau.
Also um genau zu sein, eher die Spielmelodie, nicht die Anfangsmelodie. Nee, weil ich habe nämlich immer diese Spielmelodie, die hat, wir haben das Spiel halt wochenlang gezockt ohne Ende. Ich und mein Kumpel. Und jedenfalls, diese Melodie ging meinen Eltern so dermaßen auf. Sie konnten es halt nicht mehr hören. Und so vor gut einem Jahr, anderthalb Jahren so bisher, habe ich mal meinen PC, meinen 64-Emulator drauf gemacht und habe das Spiel mal wieder angeschmissen. Und mein Vater hat dann in dem Moment aus dem Wohnzimmer geschrieben, macht das Ding aus. Weil er konnte diese Musik nicht mehr hören. Er hat sie sofort wiedererkannt.
Das ist Konditionierung.
Ja, die Rechteck-Sounds sind auch, glaube ich, eher was für Feinschmecker. Also, ist nicht jedermanns Sache.
Ja, aber das Spiel war absolut genial und...
Auf jeden Fall...
.war monatelang füllend.
Bubble-Bubbling war auch ein richtiges Multiplayer-Spiel, ne?
Du hattest mit der Iris zusammen gewusst, dass die Melodie von Summer Games da gespielt worden ist, ne?
Ja.
Das würde mich interessieren, wie viele Joysticks sind bei dir draufgegangen, bei Summer Games?
Einige, ich sag mal so... Also, wir hatten, ich und mein Kumpel, wir hatten, sag ich mal, die Woche vier, fünf, sechs Joysticks aufgeraucht, ohne Probleme.
Und? Hattet ihr so bestimmte Präferenzen? Also, es gab Leute, die haben gesagt, irgendwie Quickshot Pro mit Mikroschaltern, irgendwie was anderes kommt mir nicht ins Haus. War das bei euch ähnlich?
Wir hatten hier auch diese Competition Pro.
Quickshot war die Billig-Variante, die war dann irgendwie...
Der hatte Autofire oder so.
Autofire, aber war irgendwie schnell durchgenudelt und gerade bei Summer Games war das tödlich.
Nicht so leicht zu reparieren.
Aber der Vorteil war, man konnte immer aus zwei, drei, vier Joysticks immer wieder einen zusammenbauen. Weil halt Mikroschalter haben halt sehr lange überlebt, nur das Plastik ging halt oft kaputt. Aber als alter Bastelhainich hat man immer wieder welche hingekriegt.
Also meine Theorie ist, dass Summer Games tatsächlich halt eine Verschwörung der Joystickherstellenden Industrie war, um dafür mehr Absatz zu sorgen. Also es war ein einziges Gerüttel und Gewälde mit dem Joystick. Und ja, nach so einem harten Fight war das dann auch irgendwie vorbei mit dem Joystick.
Axel, vielen Dank. Jut, tschüss und viel Spaß mit Iris. Ich mache nur unter CD und den Ausgaben, nicht? Wir haben eine harte Korrektur erfahren hier im Chat. Muss ich jetzt mal ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht von unserem kollektiven Wissen hier im Studio. Monkey Island gab es niemals für den C64.
Ist dem so?
Also ich kann jetzt nur zitieren. Und Wetter sagt das hier im Chat.
Das ist aber komisch.
Stößt euch das jetzt auch ein bisschen für den Kopf? Ich meine, mich stößt es deswegen vor den Kopf, weil wir können die Melodie ja nochmal spielen. Die Melodie ist eigentlich klassisch C64, oder?
Das ist ein zit.
Wir spielen das nochmal für all die Ungläubigen. Ich hab Track 1, das muss ich jetzt nochmal nachschauen. So, auf geht's. Da könnte es noch alles sein, aber gleich, wenn es dann so abgeht, so richtig.
Das ist C64.
Das hört sich an, könnte auch scheinen, dass die Systeme in ähnlichen Tönen gearbeitet haben. Hörst du sie fast genauso an den. Also, da müsste schon jemand arg getäuscht haben, um das hier irgendwie durchzusetzen. Aber gut, wir haben uns mit dieser Kritik auseinandergesetzt, das zumindest. Ach so, nee, das verraten wir nicht. Gut, schauen wir mal, wer noch am Telefon ist. Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf Fritz und das Ganze im Blue Moon. Und das soll ja auch noch mal offiziell bestätigt sein. Das Chaosradio, die 74. Ausgabe zu Gast aus Köln, der Jens und der Mario. Mein Name ist Max von Malodki und es geht um Spiele und zwar Klassiker und wie sie uns geprägt haben und wie sie die Spielewelt an sich und die Welt an sich geprägt haben. Am Telefon ist der Simon, wie ich hoffe. Simon?
Ja, hallo. Ich wollte euch erzählen, wie ich mit dem Colossus Cave Adventure Englisch gelernt habe. Ja, das war vor urig langer Zeit. Ich mit sieben, acht Jahren. Meine Mutter hat sich ein C64 gekauft, erstaunlicherweise. Und wir haben da immer gesessen und gespielt und an diesem Colossus Cave Adventure herumgerätelt. Sie mit einem gesunden Halbwissen von Englisch, mich mit einem gesunden gar nicht Wissen von Englisch.
Vorher. Und irgendwann kommt ihr an die Stelle, wo es heißt, you are in a maze of twisty little passages all alike. Du bist in einem Labyrinth, kleiner, verschlungener Pfade, die alle gleich uns sehen.
Infotainment, genau. Beziehungsweise you are in a maze of twisty little passages all different.
Ja, das gab es auch, genau.
Was noch schlimmer.
Den ersten Teil von dem Ding haben wir ja durchgespielt. Das war diese Level 9 Computing Ausgabe, die haben noch zwei Teile dran gestrickt. Plus im zweiten Teil hieß es dann stellenweise, you are under water, you cannot breath und irgendwie hatten wir dann nicht raus, wie man da unter Wasser eigentlich atmen konnte. Da war irgendein Spezialgegenstand für nötig.
Ich fand das super.
Absaufen.
Irgendwie, es ging nicht.
Hinterher habe ich es dann noch mal auf dem C64 Immolator rausgekramt und festgestellt, dass man dazu so eine magische Muskel brauchte oder sowas, mit der man dann wiederum nicht an Land atmen konnte.
Also ich bin sicher, im Internet wird man da für nicht, wenn man da jetzt heutzutage noch rätselt, wie das Spiel zu lösen ist. Da gibt es auf jeden Fall irgendwie Schritt für Schritt Anleitungen. Das war auch damals einer der Hauptgründe, warum man sich diese asyligen Computer-Zeitschriften gekauft hat.
Aktuell ist es auf dem Markt, IP Computer.
Ich sage nur ein Abdruck des Computer-Listings, dann tippt man es wortgetreu, buchstabengetreu ab und es läuft nicht. Und man muss an dem Programmcode umrätseln, warum es nicht läuft.
Richtig, weil irgendeine Data-Zeile in Zeile 3900 irgendwas war falsch.
Dafür musste man die nächste Ausgabe kaufen.
Oh Gott, das hört sich wirklich ganz, ganz tief betrübt an.
Das sind Abgründe, das sind Abgründe, die sich auftun.
Also es war schön, also man saß irgendwie im Kreise der Familie und statt irgendwie Hausmusik zu machen, saß man halt am Computer und hat irgendwie in Staffetten dann halt diese Data-Zahlen eingetippt. Ich fand das sehr kommunikativ.
Natürlich, am Ende weiß man dann zumindest, wie man so ein C64 zu programmieren hat.
Richtig, und irgendwann gab es dann auch so Hilfen zur Eingabe, Check-Summe und sowas, das half dann noch eine Menge, oder?
Natürlich, aber der Check-Summe, der funktionierte doch nur mit speziell darauf abgestellten Programmen. Nur wenn man ein Programm hat, das auch mit diesen Check-Summen zusammenarbeitet, dann funktioniert das auch richtig. Ich erinnere mich nur, ich habe mal irgendwann die zweite Version vom MSI gekriegt und die Programme von der ersten Session liefen nicht mehr damit. Maschinensprache-Interpreter für das Gerät. Man zippt alles ein, jagt es durch den Interpreter und hat, wenn alles klappt, ein fertiges Programm. Wehe man hat auch nur eine Zahl falsch.
Ja, da kann man sich mal ungefähr vorstellen, weil das ist ja nun wirklich jetzt deep, dass das, was man mit Windows an Problemen hat momentan und mit dem, was Bill Gates momentan so auf den Markt schmeißt, dass das alles nur Killifig ist gegen das, was man früher so machen musste, um einigermaßen was auf die Beine zu kriegen.
Da muss ich wieder sprechen. Früher konnte man die Computer noch richtig programmieren.
Aber konnte er sie in der Gänze verstehen?
Eigentlich.
Heutzutage geben sie einem nur eine kryptische Fehlermeldung, die sagt, irgendwas ist falsch.
Ja, und gerade Windows sagt ja meistens nur, drücken sie OK.
Beziehungsweise schwerer Ausnahmefehler 0D in Schweicherstelle so und so.
Genau. Falsch, Fragezeichen.
OK.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur noch mal kurz eine Lanze brechen für zum Beispiel Windows XP. Aber wenn keiner mitbrechen möchte, dann breche ich halt die Lanze auch nicht.
Nee, nee, ich würde lieber bei den Apple II reden. 1979, der erste Ultimateil erscheinend.
Ich kann noch was zum Apple II sagen. Apple II und Spiele, das war ja vor einer Zeit das Thema. Wizardry.
Erzähl mal ein bisschen was von Wizardry, das würden die meisten wahrscheinlich gar nicht kennen.
Zu Wizardry zu den ersten Teilen kann ich gar nichts sagen. Ich bin erst im siebten Teil in die Reihe eingestiegen.
Und das gab's auf dem Apple?
Nein, den siebten Teil gab's genau wie den sechsten nur auf dem PC. Unter DOS.
Genau. Sah auch ein bisschen so aus. Aber war ein tolles Spiel.
Weil Teil sieben hatte durchgängig 256 Farbengrafik und ich spiele immer noch darum.
Es ist ja auch super komplex, man hat unheimlich viele Charakterklassen, es ist ein Rollenspiel, man kann auch aufsteigen bis zum geht nicht mehr, oder?
Na, zumindest ziemlich weit. Zumindest wenn man dann irgendwann mit einer Charakterklasse in Level 15 oder so ankam, konnte man in eine höhere, bessere wechseln und auf Level 1 wieder anfangen. Aber mit den Hitpoints und den angefangene Fertigkeiten.
Wir atmen schon gar nicht mehr, wir sind immer noch eindruckt hier. Also wirklich.
Ihr seid sprachlos.
Ja, richtig. Simon, vielen Dank. Ja, wenn ihr ähnliche Geschichten habt, ihr könnt noch anrufen, die Leitungen sind ziemlich voll. Wir arbeiten jetzt erst mal hier ab, was ihr so an Möglichkeiten habt. 0377 97 110, die Nummer sage ich trotzdem mal, fürs Chaosradio heute Abend und am Telefon ist der Andi. Hallo Andi? Andi? Ja, lange gewartet, das kann ich verstehen, dass man sich dann da auch mal verabschiedet, den Teilen zumindest. Vielleicht ist der Tino ja noch da. Auch ein sehr, sehr lange wartender Mensch. Hallo Tino.
Hallo. Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nochmal das... Ich wollte eigentlich nochmal DOS verteidigen, weil da vorher jemand angerufen hat und gesagt hat, das sind das tierische Aufgerüchter bei DOS mit dem Eingeben.
Gerade das finde ich aber...
Also, erstens finde ich gerade das praktisch, weil bei Windows kann man sich so dermaßen verklicken und man weiß dann oft gar nicht, was das jetzt überhaupt alles auslösen kann und so.
Ich will nicht zu sehr Windows bashen, das brauche ich zum Quake spielen, aber natürlich war DOS das bessere System.
Nein, Unix war natürlich das beste System.
Ja, aber noch ein anderer Grund. Es gibt oder gab für DOS solche Spiele, das fällt auch unter die Kategorie Adventure Games, solche Spiele wie Toonstruck, wenn euch das so sagt. Toonstruck oder Orion Burger, wo sich die Charaktere wunderbar miteinander unterhalten konnten. Man hat jemanden angesprochen, da waren mehrere Fragen zur Auswahl. Man hat jemanden angeklickt, die Figur hat diese Frage ausgesprochen, ihr Gegenüber hat dann halt darauf geantwortet, bis man irgendwelche Sachen erfahren konnte, mit denen man dann Rätsel gelöst hat. Ich habe bis jetzt nur ein Spiel gefunden für Windows, das so in dieser Art ist, das war Galador. Und ich habe bisher noch nie so ein anderes Spiel, deshalb würde ich schon alleine deswegen bei DOS bleiben.
Ich glaube dieses Never-Winter-Nights, da verlaufen die Dialoge ähnlich, man kriegt auch mal je nachdem, was man anklickt, andere Möglichkeiten. Ich glaube schon, dass es beschränkter geworden ist. Man hat zwar bei Never-Winter-Nights mehrere Enden, abhängig davon, wie man sich verhält, aber die Dialoge sind nicht mehr so ausgearbeitet wie früher.
Bei manchen ist es ja so, man sieht noch auf dem Bildschirm, wie jetzt die eine Figur zu der anderen was sagt, aber es war halt bei den anderen richtig klar. Man hat noch so einen ordentlichen Soundtrack gehabt, so richtig schöne Hintergrundmelodien manchmal, und halt die Figuren haben sich richtig miteinander unterhalten.
Also, Neverwinter Nights, um da nochmal kurz einzusteigen, weil es ja relativ aktuell ist, ist sehr, sehr cool in dem Punkt. Man hat sehr, sehr viel zu lesen, also am Anfang fast zu viel. Die reden richtig viel mit einem. Wenn du ein Spiel haben willst, was momentan richtig top ist, und was da noch besser gestrickt ist, wie ich finde, ist Morrowind. Das habe ich mir nämlich schon für die Xbox besorgt.
Das ist der Hammer.
Das ist der absolute Hammer, weil die Leute einem auch entgegenkommen auf naht und weil sie je nachdem, ob sie einen mögen oder nicht, von seiner Einstellung her, ob man was falsch gemacht hat in seinem Leben usw. was man da hat in diesem Rollenspiel, kommen sie auf einen zu und sagen halt, sie möchten nicht mit dir sprechen oder solange du das und das trägst, wollen sie mit dir nichts zu tun haben und so.
Sehr cool. Also mir ist das grafisch fast schon zu aufwendig, was da so an den neuen Rollenspielen aufkommt. Also ich mag immer noch Baldur's Gate 2, den Vorgänger von Neverwinter Nights.
Da sagen ja auch viele, der soll besser sein als Neverwinter Nights selber.
Ich fand die Intro-Com Text-Adventure grafisch eigentlich völlig ausreichend.
Tino? Ja, DOS-Verteidigen, das ist im Grunde dein Ansatz gewesen. Das kann man auch immer wieder tun. Und man kann auch immer wieder zu Spielen zurückkehren, die man gut fand. Aber vielleicht, wenn du Bock hast, guck dich immer um. Also entweder du holst dir die Klassiker aus dem Netz. Ich glaube sowas wie Infocom und diese ganzen Sachen Zwerg, die kann man mittlerweile sogar runterladen. Habt ihr ein paar Adressen auf Lager?
Also es gibt ein Ding, das nennt sich EF Archive. EF für Interactive Fiction. EF archive.org. Und da gibt es eine Menge Sachen, auch neu geschriebene Spiele, die in diesem Infocom-Standard, diese sogenannte Z-Maschine, verfasst sind. Und da kann man irgendwie tagelang Spaß haben. Es ist auch relativ easy, diese Programmiersprache zu lernen, wo man dann im Stil dieser Infocom-Adventures selber Spiele schreiben kann.
Auch Infocom ist ja auch erst 13 Jahre tot, 1989 aufgelöst. Glaubt ihr haben dann doch versucht, zu tun, was sie mal vorhatten? Eine Textverarbeitung schreiben?
Eine Datenbank war es dann.
Daran sind sie dann gescheitert. Wären sie doch bei den Spielen geblieben? Jens würde sich freuen.
Naja, nee, aber wer auch noch so eine DOS-Spiele sucht, ich kann nur empfehlen so etwas wie Toonstruck oder so. Das ist echt bis jetzt das, also mit das Beste, was ich gespielt habe. Oder spielen lassen habe. Eine Frage habe ich aber noch. Und zwar, ihr hattet jetzt hier Datenraten, oder wie das jetzt genannt wurde, dieses Spiel. Kann man da irgendwo die CDs, von denen ihr die Titel, also so CDs mit Computerspiel-Soundtracks oder so, kann man ja so kaufen oder so? Nicht wirklich.
Du kannst ja, wenn du Internet hast, kannst du dir sowas aus dem Netz holen. Da gibt es die High Voltage Sit Collection. Ich glaube, das sind 30 MB gepackt. Und wenn du das entpackst, dann hast du über 100 Spielemelodien. 1000.
Diese Melodien hat irgendwie Mario in mühsamer Kleinarbeit jetzt zusammengestellt nur für diese Sendung.
Ich habe gedacht, die gab es im Handel.
Ja, war eine gute Idee, denke ich.
Wie ist das eigentlich mit den Rechten? Seid ihr da informiert, wie das läuft? Weil viele dieser alten Spiele dürfen ja irgendwann ins Netz gestellt werden. Oder zumindest mit, wenn die Firma sagt, du darfst es tun und so. Man findet ja ganz viel.
Und das ist nicht mal illegal, ne? Es wird gemacht. Man spricht davon Abandonware, also irgendwie aufgegebene Software. Ist unklar. Also die meisten Dinge sind irgendwie nach wie vor Copyright behaftet. Und wenn sich da jetzt jemand dransetzen würde, könnte da auch irgendwie noch was passieren. In 99, 9% aller Fällen passiert halt nichts. Und irgendwie, ja, das Internet ist weit. Und irgendwie, da findet man dann halt letztendlich alles. Wir haben leider irgendwie gerade in den USA eine ziemlich beschissene Copyright-Situation. Das spezielle Disney-Gesetz hat dann gesagt, irgendwie noch mal nach dem Tod des Urhebers nochmal 30 Jahre drauf und so weiter. Wir werden also alle irgendwie den Zustand nicht mehr erleben, dass es noch Hardware gibt, die die Spiele abspielen kann, die jetzt irgendwie ohne Copyright frei verfügbar sind.
Schade, schade, schade. Aber aus dem Grund wird wahrscheinlich, weil bei den Musikern liegen die Rechte ja dann nochmal anders, da wird es dann wahrscheinlich auch schwer sein, eine CD damit zu machen und dann die Rechte von den damaligen Komponisten zusammenzukriegen.
Also das gibt es gerade die Stars in dieser Komponisten-Szene, wie Ron Hubbard, Chris Hülsberg etc. Die haben durchaus dann auch Alben herausgegeben mit ihren größten Hits.
Schade eigentlich. Pur wäre auch okay gewesen. Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0373 110. Beim Chaosradio um Spiele geht es im Studio nochmal, damit ihr die Stimme auch so ein bisschen zuordnen könnt. Der Jens und der Mario aus Köln. Und Max von Malodkia am Mikrofon. Und am Telefon ist der Jonathan. Hallo Jonathan.
Hallo.
Nabend.
Ich wollte einfach mal in die ganze Runde noch das supergeniale Spiel müsst werfen. Ich weiß nicht, wer es bis zu Ende gespielt hat. Ich weiß nicht, wer die Bücher gelesen hat. Aber da ist ja mittlerweile ein ganzer Kultrum umentstanden. Und es steht ja auch in den Startlöchern für nächstes Jahr wohl noch Myst 4 und ein riesen Online-Projekt von der mittlerweile umgenannten Firma Cyan Worlds.
Es gibt Myst 2 für Linux. Wollte ich nur einwerfen.
Aber das ist nicht Myst.
Oh, da gibt es einen Unterschied.
Ja, also Myst und Myst sind komplett andere Titel.
Ich google mal eben.
Sekunde, würdest du mal buchstabieren, weil im Radio...
M-Y-S-T.
Ja, ist Myst.
Nein, das ist meins. Und dann gibt es dieses M-Y-T-H. Die Myst, Myst, wie auch immer Serie. Ja, die haben auch eine Linux-Version raus. Myst, das was ich meine leider nicht, aber die sind gut auf Mac vertreten, das tut es auch dann. Und da bin ich mittlerweile eben wirklich auch am Sammeln, weil mich die einfach nicht loslassen.
Also die Mac-User konnten zumindest bei Myst immer sagen, ja, aber. Wenn die PC-User halt gesagt haben, auf Mac kann man ja nicht spielen. Und unheimlich viele Leute haben sich nur für Myst halt ein CD-Rom-Laufwerk gekauft.
Ja, wobei auf Mac kam ja noch überhaupt das erste so fotorealistische Clicky-Clicky-Spiel war The Journeyman Project. Das war der Auslöser für meinen Vater, sich damals ein CD-Rom-Laufwerk zu kaufen. Das war noch etwa ein halbes Jahr von Myst in etwa. Aber das trifft so ziemlich genau die Zeit. Und Myst war eigentlich auch so, naja, ich sag mal, zählt zumindest in die Anfänge meiner Spielezeit, wo ich dann bei meinem Vater ein bisschen rumgeklickt habe. Zwar nicht viel verstanden hab, weil die Mac-Versionen ja alle Englisch waren, aber so im Laufe der Zeit kam dann alles. Und ja, mittlerweile total hin und weg. Und Myst wurde dann ja auch für etliche Spielekonsolen noch umgesetzt. Also da, weil eine Flu-PC mittlerweile...
Hast du auch die Nachfolger alle gespielt?
Den dritten Teil leider noch nicht. Der liegt mittlerweile zweimal in deutscher und in englischer Ausführungen bei mir auf dem Schreibtisch. Aber ich finde in letzter Zeit irgendwie so wenig Zeit zum Spielen. Aber er soll auch genial sein, da habe ich die Bücher gelesen.
Das macht auf jeden Fall Spaß. Ich habe mich an Teil 2 ja nie rangewagt. Bei dem gab es ja auch das Gerücht, dass der ohne Hilfe unlösbar gewesen sei.
Ich habe den mit Hilfe etlicher Leute kollektiv dann irgendwann doch gepackt, ja.
Ja, Multigehörn, das kann ja jeder.
Das war bei Sam und Max früher auch nötig. Also Sam und Max habe ich auch nicht alleine. Naja, ein bisschen alter, tümliche Anziehung. Aber dafür soll der dritte Teil umso leichter sein.
Er ist wie ein Kinofilm mit ein paar Rätseln. Aber er macht auch Spaß. Also sollte man jetzt nicht so runter machen.
Ja, da freue ich mich jetzt auch schon richtig irgendwie drauf, weil langsam fängt hier wieder alles an zu laufen. Dann werde ich mich da auch mal ran machen und für nächstes Jahr natürlich groß auf der Wunschliste oder Warteliste die beiden folgenden dann.
Also ideologisch sozusagen war der Vorgänger dann vielleicht dieses Dragon Slayer. Von wann kannst du noch mal nachgucken?
Dragon Slayer 1983.
1983.
Das erste Spiel, der Automat allerdings, nicht die Amiga-Umsetzung mit Laserdisc.
Mit Laserdisc und war vom Gameplay unter all der Sau. Also eigentlich ein Spielfilm, wo man an einigen Stellen dann sich entscheiden konnte, ja, gehe ich nach rechts, dann sterbe ich, oder gehe ich nach links, dann geht das Spiel irgendwie weiter.
Aber Dragon Slayer wurde mittlerweile, glaube ich, auch als DVD umgesetzt. Dann kann man das am DVD-Player, am Fernseher irgendwie spielen.
Ja genau, der dann auch irgendwie Feivel, der Mauswanderer und solche Sachen gemacht hat. Der hat dann irgendwie komplett im Comic-Stil dieses Dings gemacht. Und damals hat Mark gesagt, Akkadeautomaten mit Videoscheibe, Laser-Disc, das wird die große Zukunft sein. War auch total beeindruckend, war aber irgendwie super langweilig, das Spiel eigentlich. Na ja, klar.
Wenn es schon Richtung Spielhallen geht, dann muss ich sagen, House of the Dead ist einfach etwas da, da komme ich auch nicht mehr von los. Sich einfach vor so einen Teil zu stellen, zu zweit und dann kollektiv auf den Bildschirm ballern, also.
Und so, ja, weiß nicht, sozial-ethisch desorientiert bist du dadurch nicht geworden, oder?
Wegen House of the Dead? Nicht wirklich. Also mir geht es noch gut und...
Ach und deinem Freund?
Du sagtest mit zwei Leuten irgendwie sowas.
Ja, ach der, dem geht es auch. Außerdem im Übrigen, das muss man ja nicht immer mit Leuten vom gleichen Geschlecht spielen, also ich habe das auch schon mit meiner Freundin gespielt. Die waren, also das war jetzt gerade vor kurzem im Prag waren wir in so einer Spielhalle und hatten zwei Mädels dabei, die waren hin und weg von dem Teil. Die haben sich ja auch vorgestellt und geballert, da war ich wieder etwas fasziniert von, aber...
Also Mario hat ja eine ganz eigene Theorie zum Thema Frauen und Computerspiele. Man sucht ja immer so nach der Frauen-Computerspiel-Szene und findet sie nirgendswo.
Ich würde ja sagen, wir lassen das als kleines Geheimnis die nächsten 10 Minuten noch stehen und begeben uns erstmal in die Nachrichten ins FritzInfo. Ist das ein Cliffhanger? Jonathan, dank dir.
Wenn Fritz in Frankfurt oder dann 101, 5.
0, 30 haben wir es nämlich. Mit dem Wetter ist es wechselnd bewölkt. Bei 21 bis 16 Grad am Tag Anfangs noch alter, später teils kräftige Gewitter. Bei 23 bis 27 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Berner.
Die PDR Spitze hat den Rückzug ihres früheren Parteichefs Gizzi von allen politischen Ämtern bedauert. Die Vorsitzende Zimmerzollte Gizzi Respekt bezeichnete seine Entscheidung, aber als überzogen. Gizzi war am Abend als Berliner Wirtschaftssenator und Bürgermeister zurückgetreten. Er legte auch sein Abgeordnetenhausmandat nieder. Für heute ist eine Sondersitzung des Senats geplant. Bundestagspräsident Thierse hat der Lufthansa in der Bonusmeilnaffäre ein Ultimatum gestellt. In einem Brief forderte er bis heute Nachmittag eine Liste der Abgeordneten, die mit Bonusmeilen geflogen sind. Thierse erklärte, dass die von der Bildzeitung verwendeten Daten nur von der Lufthansa stammen könnten. Die beiden in Südsudan verschleppten Deutschen sind nach Angaben eines UN-Vertreters wohlauf. Man könne ungehindert mit ihnen sprechen, hieß es. Bewaffnete Männer hatten am Montag ein Lager der internationalen Hilfsorganisation World Vision überfallen und zwei deutsche Mitarbeiter verschleppt. Bei einem Bombenanschlag auf die Universität von Jerusalem sind sieben Menschen getötet und mehr als 85 verletzt worden. Der Sprengsatz explodierte in der Cafeteria des Internationalen Studentenzentrums. Zu der Tat bekannte sich die radikali-islamische Hamas-Organisation. Und zum Sport bei den Schwimm-Europameisterschaften hat Franziska van Almsik den Titel über 100 Meter Freistil gewonnen. Für van Almsik war es nach zwei Siegen in der Staffel bereits die dritte Goldmedaille bei den Titelkämpfen. Und der Verkehr auf Fritz hat keine Meldungen, also gute Fahrt.
Und wer Geburtstag hat, kommt mit sechs Freunden einfach so rein. Sommer, Hitz und Fete.
Und ihr hört immer noch das Chaosradio, den Fritz Blue Moon Spezialversion, immer den letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Und heute, die 74. Ausgabe, da dreht es sich komplett um Spiele und um Spiele Klassiker. Zu Gast im Studio sind wir im Grunde alle drei. Der Jens und der Mario vom Chaos Computer Club aus Köln. Und Malodki am Mikrofon. Noch ein Plus oben drauf. Eine E-Mail-Adresse könnten wir noch mal kurz ansagen, damit ihr wisst, wo ihr hin schicken soll, den Sachen Feedback für diese Sendung, dass die 74. Ausgabe ist. Wir hatten das bereits erwähnt.
74.at chaosradio.ccc.de Oui, Cissat.
Exaktement. Und am Telefon haben wir den...
Nee.
Bevor wir das machen, wir hatten vorhin ja einen kleinen Cliffhanger gebastelt.
Ja, genau.
Es ging um Geschlechtsspezifisches in Sachen Computerspiele. Und da hatte der Mario sich schon in Gedanken sehr weit vorgewagt und wird jetzt wahrscheinlich die Bombe platzen lassen, indem er ganz banal sagt, ich sehe da gar nichts.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wir haben das vorher diskutiert, ob dieses Thema kommen soll und ich habe natürlich gesagt, nee, warum, was soll dieses Thema? Wir haben quasi viel zu wenig Frauen am Computer, als das man jetzt hergehen sollte und da irgendwie eine Quotenfrau suchen. Wenn man auf Lennparties guckt, da ist eine und das, was sie da spielt, naja, das ist dann auch noch meistens auf dem Rechner ihres Freundes.
Und sie spielt?
Ja, Sonitär oder Tetris. Oder ein Adventure. Ich glaube, dass es bei Konsolen anders aussieht. Ich glaube, dass es mit dem Zugang zu Computern zu tun hat, der immer noch irgendwie minder dominiert ist. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob das in der Familie so läuft, dass dein Vater sagt, na guck mal, dein Bruder hat doch schon einen Computer, benutz den doch mit, du brauchst doch nicht einen eigenen oder so. Ich weiß es nicht.
Also irgendwie, ja, Jungs spielen Doom, Mädchen spielen Barbie. Ich habe immer noch so die Hoffnung, dass es so was wie eine weibliche Gamer-Szene gibt. Mir fehlen aber irgendwie die Belege. Es soll jetzt irgendwie gerade heute auf Heise gelesen so eine LAN-Party für Mädchen geben, wo dann irgendwie ein Spiel gespielt wird, wo Mädchen auf irgendwelchen Elfen rumklicken.
Ja, also auch wieder total süß, ne?
Ja, also Rollen-Klischee ist halt ein Lernen, ein Trainieren am Computer. Und ich frage mich, ob das halt wirklich das ist, was Frauen oder Mädchen irgendwie anmacht.
Ist denn das wirklich so, ist dieser Trieb sich zu vergleichen, ist das ein rein männlicher, ist das das Kind im Manne? Oder wollen Frauen auch spielen? Ich meine, wir wollen auch alle spielen, oder?
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass irgendwie dieser Adrenalinkick beim Spielen irgendwie auch bei Frauen existieren könnte oder sowas. Ich weigere mich halt irgendwie zu glauben, dass das eine rein männliche Geschichte wäre. Und ich würde mich gerne von einer Anruferin überzeugen lassen.
Ja, können wir mal schauen, ob das noch funktioniert. Also die Hauptantwort, die ich bekommen habe aus der weiblichen Riege, war ja immer die, dass da... also eher immer so ein Schulterzucken und so ein Ja, was soll ich da spielen? Das ist doch langweilig. Das ist doch unsinn, das bringt doch nichts. Also wenn man dann entgegengesetzt angeführt hat, warum schminkst du dich denn dann eine Stunde, wenn die Dame das getan hat? Das ist jetzt nicht bei jeder Frau so, aber es gibt ja schon welche, die sich dann auch damit beschäftigen. Oder warum gehst du die ganze Zeit Klamotten shoppen? Das sind ja so die anderen Klischees von der Frauenseite.
Das war dann immer okay.
Das war normal. Das war ja normales Leben. Ich finde, dass Computerspiele immer noch nicht so den Einzug ins normale Leben gefunden haben und dass die meisten das noch nicht darunter verstehen, dass das dazu gehört. Das ist halt noch keine Freizeitbeschäftigung. Aber ich kann auch positive Beispiele anführen. Meine Freundin zum Beispiel liebt Oddworld. Hier dieses Munch's Odyssey. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt. Der letzte Oddworld-Teil. Es ist ein Adventure. Es ist auf der Xbox erschienen. Es gibt auch ziemlich viele Teile davon. Aber es hat halt richtig coole Charaktere, macht Spaß, sieht schön aus. Sehr wichtig. Und was auch mal bei einer weiblichen Bekanntenfamilie gefunden hat, ist Dracan gewesen. War so ein 3D-Shooter mit so einem Drachen und so.
Der war so ein schwertschwingender Typ, ne Frau.
Der mit dem Typen ist Rune. Es war nämlich eine Frau. Und, und das ist nicht zu unterschätzen, dieser Drache, und jetzt kommt's, hatte die Synchronstimme von Sean Connery. Und er hatte so was wie eine Vaterfigur. Und ich glaube, das ist manchmal gar nicht so unwichtig.
Aber das ist so schlimm. Das ist so schlimm. Das sind irgendwie Klischees, die da bedient werden.
Das will man nicht glauben eigentlich. Ja, aber hey, wo sind die weiblichen Counterstrikerinnen, die Quakerinnen? Ja, da freut mich das hier mit dem Spielautomaten, was wir gerade gehört haben, wo die Freundinnen dann mitgespielt haben. Das hört sich eher nach wirklichen Zockersälen an.
Na ja, probieren wir's mal mit Johannes. Hallo Johannes. Johannes, bist du noch da? Nicht mehr. Dann schauen wir mal.
Ich wollte die Geschichte mit diesem mysteriösen Monkey Island-Sit auflösen.
Oh, bitte, bitte.
Das kommt uns natürlich gelegen.
Ja, und zwar ist das einfach nur, ich sag mal, eine Cover-Version vom original PC-Track oder Amiga-Track, wie auch immer. So wie es auch irgendwie 3 Milliarden Excel-F Sits für den 64er gibt.
Es ist halt genau... Genau viel Monkey Island gab es für den 64er nicht.
Wäre auch spät gewesen, kam glaube ich 1980.
Ja, 1982 ging es irgendwie weg von diesen Videospiel-Konsolen und hin zu den Heimcomputern. Da begann eigentlich dann die moderne Geschichtsschreibung.
Und dann hat Nintendo sicherlich irgendwo viel vorausgedacht. Das waren auch die ersten, die Spiele Designer eingesetzt haben. Also da haben nicht nur die Programmierer gedacht, sondern irgendwann hatten wir richtige Designer. Und die haben auch noch mal so ein bisschen den Konsolenmarkt nach dem großen Crash so niederbelebt.
Sebastian, dann hast du uns wenigstens bei der Lösung dieses externen Monkey Island Rätsels geholfen. Aber warte mal kurz. Hast du eine Freundin, eine Bekannte, die als Zockerin zu werden wäre?
Na ja, wenn Adventures als Zocken gelten, ja.
Aber sonst natürlich nicht.
Geringe Komplexität scheint in Ordnung zu sein.
Mario, du bist ein Schovi.
Das mache ich nur, weil der Jens das hören will. Na ja, ich meine in der Steuerung. Also ich erlebe das einfach selten, dass die sagen, ich finde das gut hier, da muss ich die Maus und die Tastatur gleichzeitig und außerdem muss ich noch 20-Tasten-Kombinationen kennen. Also irgendwie scheint das so zu sein, dass irgendwie dieser Zugang zum Computer generell fehlt. Deshalb beschwert man sich auch immer über die wenigen Programmiererinnen. Und dann auch, wenn man sich diese Initiativen anguckt, da werden Frauen immer in diese Designer-Ecke gedrängt wirklich. Die lernen dann nicht irgendwie, wie programmiere ich Ruhe oder so. Die lernen, wie mache ich HTML-Seiten. Frauen haben natürlich klischee-mäßig Farbgefühl.
Aber ich habe auch noch keinen Typen gesehen, Mario, der gesagt hätte, oh geil, da muss ich wieder 40-Tasten-Kombinationen auswendig lernen. Da bin ich ja mega geil drauf. Das habe ich auch noch nicht erlebt.
Ich glaube, Mario ist so einer.
Na, man wird spielen.
Ja, am Telefon ist jetzt vielleicht, wenn er noch dran ist und gewartet hat, der Martin. Hallo Martin. Martin? Nee, dann vielleicht der Burkhardt. Auch nicht. Oh, das geht schnell heute.
Ich meine, wie erklärst du denn dann den Erfolg von diesem Microsoft-Flugsimulator? Also den kann man doch ohne 20-Tasten-Kombinationen gar nicht spielen. Und der Bill Gates besteht seitdem dieses Windows hat darauf, dass dieses Spiel irgendwie weiterentwickelt wird.
Terrorgruppen in Afghanistan? Womit sollen die denn üben?
Da sind ja die wichtigen Ziele rausgelöscht worden.
Ja, sicher. Und deswegen wird sich das Ganze jetzt auch nicht mehr verkaufen. Nur noch Apples to Fly, verstehst du? Weil dann neue Ziele mit dabei sind. Das ist noch net on. So sieht's nämlich aus. Aber das ist eine Verschwörungstheorie. Das solltet ihr nicht so ernst nehmen in Berlin und Brandenburg. Es schließt hier auch noch Chaosradio. Der Peter ist am Telefon. Hallo? Peter? Weißt du, was das Problem ist? Viele Leute warten eine Sekunde und gehen dann sofort aufs Klo. Hat man rausgefunden in so einer kleinen Studie. Gerade beim Radio. Weil sich das so anbietet. Das hat so was Gemütliches. Hallo Oliver?
Ich war zwischendurch auch auf dem Klo, aber wer will das?
Keine Details, das reicht uns.
Es geht hauptsächlich darum, dass es mich ziemlich annervt, dass es zu wenig richtig gute Spiele für Linux gibt. Ich bin halt ziemlich an Windows gebunden, wenn ich gute bzw. bekannte Spiele spielen will. Vor allem auch in Sachen Multiplayer. Gut, es gibt jetzt ein paar Bekannte wie Unreal Tournament oder Quake 3 oder so, die man auch unter Linux kriegt, obwohl da ja auch die Firma, die diese Portierung gemacht hat, ich glaube Loki war das, die haben ja auch dicht gemacht irgendwie oder so ähnlich.
Ja, die Spiele wurden einfach nicht oft genug gekauft, habe ich gehört. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, wie nimmst du das wahr? Also ich habe mal so nachgeguckt im Internet, also bei diesen modernen Nvidia 3D-Beschleuniger Karten, da haben wir unter Linux einen Verlust in der Geschwindigkeit, der ist kleiner, 5%. Also wir sind wirklich fast so schnell wie die Windows-Rechner. Aber irgendwie, es ist nicht so ganz dasselbe Feeling, oder?
Ich weiß nicht. Gut, die Spiele, zum Beispiel die Tee habe ich schon gemerkt, es spielt sich halt ein bisschen anders. Aber ich denke mal, dass das mehr an der Spieleumsetzung liegt und nicht am Betriebssystem.
Ja, also bei Quake fällt mir das ganz deutlich auf. Die Maus, das ist nicht dasselbe. Das ist nicht so dieses Weiche, was man so gewöhnt ist dann.
Das war ziemlich anders als auf dem PC.
Also ich glaube, irgendwie die, die richtig ernsthaften Benutzer, die dann irgendwie Linux installieren oder irgendwie andere ähnliche Unices, ähm, für die ist Spiele auch dann irgendwie so ein bisschen eBay. Also früher waren wir irgendwie alle gleich. Die Leute, die sich mit Computern beschäftigt hatten, die Spiele etc. Aber mittlerweile haben sich dann wirklich so verschiedene Stämme abgespalten. Und man muss eigentlich auch sagen, so bei uns im Chaos Computer Club, wo irgendwie gehackt wird, programmiert wird, Hardware entwickelt wird oder so, ist Spiele etwas, was ziemlich unten auf der Priorität ist.
Also ein paar Quaker hat man, wenig Counterstriker.
Aber, also, schade eigentlich. Also durch Spiele wurde halt auch irgendwie diese Computerkultur lange Zeit geprägt, aber mittlerweile hat es sich halt ab... ja, völlig in eine andere Richtung entwickelt. Und es kommen auf einmal auch so diese Leute, die, ja, das ist Pendant zum Fuchsschwanz am Opel und so weiter und Auto tieferlegen. Und die Menschen, die irgendwie ein bisschen intelligenter an den Computer rangehen, Linux benutzen, etc. die beschäftigen sich dann im Umkehrschluss nicht mehr mit Spielen, was auch schade ist.
Also ich möchte nicht jedes Mal neu booten müssen.
Naja, Linux sehe ich im Moment so, dass ich da eher nebenbei drauf spiele. Das ist auch im Moment der einzige Grund, warum ich, wie gesagt, Windows benutze. Also benutzen eigentlich Windows nicht mehr wirklich nur noch so, um zu spielen und so weiter. Linux dann so zum Arbeiten, Surfen und allem Möglichen, was man sonst noch so macht.
Genau, Mozilla ist toll, als Poser.
Oliver, dank dir.
Ich kenne eine weibliche Person, die man als Zuckerin bezeichnen könnte.
Super.
Aber leider nur Konsole.
Das ist nämlich mein anderes großes Vorurteil, für das ich schon gescholken werde. Wenn, dann spielen die gerne Konsolen spielen. Ich habe mir das auch bestätigen lassen vorhin von einer Frau, die sagte, da wollte ich auf eine Land-Party und dann habe ich überlegt, was will ich da spielen? Das waren alles Konsolenspiele.
Space Channel 5 und solche Sachen, ja.
Da hast du dann wieder so geguckt, als würden sich alle deine Klischees erfüllen. Was ist denn dieses Space Channel 5? Ist das als Einsteigerspiel geeignet?
Es ist, sagen wir mal, eher ein Mädchen-Spiel. Also es ist für die Sega Dreamcast, man spielt irgendwie einen Mädel mit rosa Haaren und Mini-Rock. Ist irgendwie so kompatibel vom Look her zu diesen japanischen Schulmädchen-Geschichten und so weiter. Und man muss Aliens besiegen, indem man besser tanzt als sie. Die Musik ist eigentlich ziemlich funky. Und es geht dann halt die ganze Zeit irgendwie Up, Left, Shoot, Shoot, Shoot. Wer es mag? Also sehr nervig.
Ihr seid niedlich.
Die Japaner, es ist aber von den Japanern rübergeschwappt, ne?
Es ist ganz eindeutig japanisch. Also noch japanischer geht es nicht.
Ja, aber das ist halt sehr freaky. Ich finde das geil. Die entwickeln wenigstens solche Sachen. Die haben auch Manga, als in denen andere Themen behandelt werden.
Ich glaube das sind doch Länder, wo das anders ist. Ich glaube, da spielen viel mehr Frauen als hier in Deutschland, in Europa.
Auf jeden Fall. Also hier, wir hatten ja das Thema Korea, glaube ich, am Anfang der Sendung und da ist in jedem Team in der Regel auch eine Frau oder zwei. Also das ist einfach gemischter da. Tja, dann lass uns mal dran arbeiten. Vielleicht können wir zum Abschluss ja nochmal, das würde mich sehr freuen, das was wir auch eigentlich angekündigt hatten in den Newsletter fürs Chaos Radio heute Abend, darauf eingehen, inwiefern Computerspiele die Entwicklung immer vorangetrieben haben. A, könnte man ja nochmal beenden, was ihr so als Zeitleister aufgezeichnet habt. Und es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass Pornografie und Computerspiele die beiden Sachen sind, die immer die technischen Entwicklungen vorangetrieben haben. Ohne Pornografie gäbe es keine Videokassetten.
Gäbe es kein Internet.
Gäbe es kein Internet. Ohne Spiele gäbe es sowas wie Online-Communities, die so gut funktionieren jetzt auch noch nicht wirklich. Und deswegen überlegen die sich jetzt auch richtig coole Bezahlsysteme.
Ich kann mal ein paar Eckdaten nennen. Wir haben nämlich gerade so die Hardware ein bisschen außen vor gelassen, also abgesehen von diesen PTP-Diskussionen. 1971, Intel entwickelte den ersten digitalen Prozessor. Also das war noch knapp vor Pong. Aber immerhin, bis der dann verkauft wurde, die waren nicht häufig zu haben, geringe Stückzahlen. Dann hat die Spieleindustrie angefangen nachzufragen und da expandierte das Geschäft. Der nächste große Punkt, denke ich, das war 75 Gunfalt, der erste Automat mit Mikrochips. Als nächstes muss man wohl, naja, die erste Konsole von Nintendo. 1977, Nintendo, auch eine ganz seltsame Firma aus einem Spielkartenhersteller entstanden. Gehen wir mal weiter. Dragon Slayer 1983, Laserdisc haben wir schon genannt. Und dann natürlich die Entwicklung in den letzten fünf, zehn Jahren. Wie lang ist es her? Die letzten Jahre sind immer so schwer einzusehen.
Man kann es auch so ein bisschen sehen bei den Computerkäufern. Also es ist schon so, man sieht dann im Laden so einen jungen Mann stehen und der sagt dann irgendwie, ja, ich möchte da gerne so einen Computer kaufen.
Was soll er denn können?
So ein bisschen Text verarbeiten.
Aha, da braucht man schon 1, 8 Gigahertz.
Spielen soll er, wollte ich da aber auch noch. Und dann merkt man so irgendwie, er verlangt nach dieser GeForce-Karte und die Reise ist eigentlich klar dann für den Verkäufer. Er soll ein Spielesystem werden.
Ich kaufe ja auch gerade so eine neue Karte. Die ist ja nur dafür da, weil ich ja zwei Monitore parallel anstrengen will. Es ist klasse, dass irgendwie 128 MB Grafikrennen sind auf der Karte, damit ich schneller quaken kann. Nein, darum geht es nicht.
Das ist für einen Systemadministrator auf jeden Fall Luft.
Auf jeden Fall brauchen wir 128 MB Grafik-Speicher.
Allerdings hat Kollege Bastian Berner, der ja Game-Schicker ist bei Fritz, auch mal erzählt, dass er auf so einer Convention war, wo die gezockt haben. Und die Quake-Zocker, die richtig professionell zocken, die fahren die Grafik ja so runter, dass das eigentlich überhaupt nichts mehr mit dem üblichen Spiel zu tun hat. Da sieht das ja nur noch so aus wie rotes Quadrat gegen gelbes Quadrat.
Ja, so sieht das auch aus. Na klar, diese ganzen Effekte, irgendwie was da so gibt, Texturen, Blut und Schreie, das will man alles gar nicht haben. Das liegt nur vom Gameplay ab. Na klar, man möchte das ganz exakt spielen, aber trotzdem schnell. Und deshalb brauche ich diese neue Karte.
Ist ja gut. Ist damit im Grunde die Zeitleiste abgefrüstückt?
Ich denke, wir könnten jetzt noch sagen, 1994 die Playstation erscheint. Und trauriges Datum, 1998 Ataris Reste gehen an Hasbro. Und 2001 Sega gibt die Hardware auf. Das war's. Traurig.
Vielleicht noch einen kleinen Ausblick auf die Zukunft?
Zukunft denke ich, dass diese Genres, die Anfang der 90er neu erfunden worden sind, das sind hauptsächlich die Ego-Shooter, denke ich, und Realtime-Strategiespiele, dass die immer stärker online gehen, in große Communities gehen, zum Multiplayer spielen werden, so wie man das bei Ultima Online sieht. Ich denke, das ist auch der Weg, also mehr Interaktivität. Es geht nicht mehr nur darum, sich gegenseitig abzuschießen, sondern es geht um den virtuellen Grundstückskauf, quasi in Adventurien.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, wie schnell das vorangehen wird, aber ich glaube ja daran, dass diese ganzen Communities, wenn es diese ganzen, es kommt ja jetzt so langsam, massively Multiplayer und solche Sachen, und dann so über 100.000 Leute auf einen graphisch sehr cool aufgepeppten Planeten unterwegs sind, dass sich dann online wirklich die ersten Königreiche, die ersten Demokratien zu bilden werden, die wirklich groß sind, und wo du nicht mehr merkst, wie viele Menschen da und da sind, dass man wirklich neue Leute kennenlernen kann. Und dass das irgendwann die wichtigere Ebene sein wird im Vergleich zu real life, dass jede Firma sich so eine eigene Welt leistet online, die großen und so. Das finde ich ziemlich spannend.
Ja, da gehen wir Richtung Cyberspace. Aber ich glaube, dass es erst mal um Spiele geht. Was dabei rausspringt, das können wir noch nicht absehen. Das erste MAD, Multi-User-Dungeon, das war 1978 an der Uni in Essex. Und ich glaube schon, dass diese grafischen Oberflächen, die wir haben, die sich weiterentwickeln, dreidimensionaler werden und hoffentlich auch weiter irgendwie detaillierter werden, dass das die Entwicklung sein wird. Und dass das auch das Ding ist, was immer mehr Leute den Zugang dazu verschafft. Weil das ist halt schon ein anderer Reiz, ob man es sehen kann, anklicken kann oder ob man es liest.
Ja, und die Gamer werden dann auch dafür sorgen, dass sie richtig ordentlich Bandbreite bekommen, weil irgendwann werden die Spiele einfach dann, ja blöd, ohne anständige Bandbreite.
Wir brauchen mehr Bandbreite.
Ja, dann werden auch irgendwie die Telekommunikationsunternehmen dann in Zugzwang geraten, weil Spiele kann man halt verkaufen irgendwie.
Und jetzt, wo wir eigentlich am Ende sind und wo alles vorbei wäre und wo wir gelechtst haben, noch eine Frau, die Computerspielerin ist. Da kommt sie und ruft an. Es ist die Tina. Hallo Tina. Und der Jens kennt sie sogar. Der Jens kennt sie sogar, sage ich.
Ich glaube nicht.
Na, vielleicht. Ich wollte nur mal auf jeden Fall was gegen diese Vorurteile sagen, dass Frauen nicht spielen, das stimmt gar nicht. Nur sind, also ich weiß nicht, also ich persönlich spiele eher Konsolenspiele. Also ich bin ein großer Fan von der DreamCast. Naja, also das von ihr erwähnte Space Channel 5 spiele ich schon auch, aber es gibt auch ein sehr cooles Spiel, das heißt House of the Dead. Und das spielt man nicht mit so einem normalen Spielpad, sondern...
Richtig, mit einer Knarre auf den Bildschirm ballern, ne?
Genau, das ist super cool.
Sehr pädagogisch auch.
Also sowas habe ich mich noch nicht getraut.
Ja, also gerade nach Erfurt ist da sicherlich ein Beitrag zur aktiven Trauerarbeit.
Genau, auf jeden Fall. Genau, und das spiele ich. Und eine Freundin von mir, Nika, die spielt auch ganz viel. Gerade spielt sie Mrs. Pacman, habe ich gehört.
Das ist übrigens speziell für die Zielgruppe Frauen herausgebracht worden.
Aber das scheint ihr sehr viel Spaß zu machen. Und ich weiß nicht, viele Leute spielen. Ich kenne eine Frau, die spielt sehr gut Quake. Also das ist alles ganz normal eigentlich.
Die Frau, die sehr gut Quake spielt, von der hört man auch häufiger.
Sehr witzig, Jens. Doch, wirklich. Es gibt immer diese... Also irgendwo kennt immer jemand jemand. Aber man sieht so wenige davon, wenn es doch nur mehr wären.
Aber wenn man so spielt, dann kriegt man ja auch wieder sehr wertvoll, was du so spielst und wo. Tue ich.
Tina, mach's gut. Und um die Statistik noch vollständig zu machen, wir haben ja hier unseren Chat über den, dass alles läuft, und da stand gerade, dass mittlerweile sich zehn Frauen gemeldet haben, die nachweislich spielen, nicht nur Channel 5 und nicht nur Adventures und nicht nur auf der Konsole. Im Grunde können wir uns an dieser Stelle auch schon verabschieden, würde ich sagen, und noch ein paar Sachen durchgeben, mit denen wir uns verabschieden. Nämlich die E-Mail-Adresse, bei der man sich melden kann, wenn man zu dieser Sendung des Chaosradios oder zu einer der nächsten oder einer der urvergangenen etwas beitragen möchte. Die E-Mail-Adresse dafür ist 74, orientiert sich an dieser Sendung, das ist nämlich die Nummer 74, 74 als Zahl, also 74, at chaosradio.ccc.de. Internetseite ist demnach auch klar, www.chaosradio.ccc.de oder wenn man spitzfindig ist, kann man das www.chaosradio.ccc.de auch weglassen. So, das wär's und im Chat kann man sich noch weiter unterhalten, wenn man möchte. Fahrt ihr jetzt eigentlich direkt zurück nach Köln?
Ja, unser eigenes Flugzeug vom Club.
Die Chaos-Flugbereitschaft.
Kein Problem, wir müssen nur aufpassen, dass wir nicht vorher ins Kino gehen.
Ja, genau. Sonst haut das irgendwie mit den Freiflügen. Also dann privat oder so.
Gut, damit würde ich sagen, schließen wir für heute Abend. Denn es ist kurz vor eins, wir geben ab an den Night Flight. Das war das Chaosradio, der Blue Moon auf Fritz. Unsere Namen waren, vielleicht nochmal selber pronunziert bitte. Jens und Mario und Max Formalotky. Und man hört sich wieder nächsten Monat, den letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Da gibt es nämlich immer das Chaosradio. Und Thema steht eigentlich auch schon fest, oder? Habt ihr das schon? Wisst ihr das zufällig?
Habt ihr das im Kopf? Das Thema nächsten Monat wird, glaube ich, es geht um Wahrheit.
Es geht um Wahrheit? Ja, das ist auch schön offen. Vielleicht ist es dann auch wirklich wahr, dass es um Wahrheit geht. Das Ganze auch für die Fritz wieder. Und jetzt ab 1 Uhr den Night Flight. Und nur damit wir das noch mal honorieren, machen wir das jetzt auch die letzten drei Minuten und spielen noch mal Musik von LN die uns hier die ganze Zeit unter unserem Talk mit einem DJ-Set begleitet hat. Der Night Flight kommt gleich mit Martin Petersdorf.